One of the problems when talking about
the Crusades is there's this deliberate
vacuum. That early in the 8th century,
Christians do not understand in any way
that this is a new religion. All of the
jihads, no matter what, were very much
motivated by just war, conquest,
enslavement.
>> 1095 when the first crusade is called
for by the pope. What is the attitude
and beliefs of Europeans? [music] This
was a traumatic event, massive change
that took place to the globe.
>> Had the Christians not engaged in just
war [music] then all of Europe and
indeed America might well be Muslim.
>> We have more records of what actually
these Turks did than what the Arabs did.
And it is some graphic stuff. Okay.
These Turks ran in killing and
slaughtering tens of thousands. The
worst one happened in 1064. They her to
death essentially.
>> Do we have a sense of how many were
killed?
>> Literally hundreds of thousands. But
this would include women and children.
Now we finally come to the Knights
Templar.
>> A total of nine knights created a band
of brotherhoods. Very soon they
essentially morphed into a elite
commando force dedicated to fighting
Islam. The logic became if we want to
protect Christians then we are in de
facto [music] war with Islam.
>> You might shut this question down but do
you think any of the crusades were just?
Before we get into this interview, I
just wanted to say that we have noticed
that more than half of our regular
viewers are not subscribed. If you want
to support the Winston Marshall Show,
all you have to do is press subscribe.
If you do that, we're going to have more
phenomenal guests exploring the issues
you want to hear about that the
mainstream media won't touch. But
without further ado, on with the
interview. Raymond Ibrahim, part two.
I'm thrilled to be sat with you again.
And now you have just put out a new
book, The Two Swords of Christ, Five
Centuries of War Between Islam and the
Warrior Monks of Christendom, focusing
on the Knights Templar and Knights
Hospital, which I'm hoping to get into
with you in this conversation, the the
truth about the Crusades.
>> Yeah.
>> So perhaps we should go right to the
beginning. Crusades actually is an
anacronistic word, right? So they
weren't called Crusades at the right at
the beginning.
>> No. Yeah, it kind of codified later, but
they were always essentially tied to the
idea of taking the cross
>> in different languages. And so cru
crusade comes from different languages,
Spanish, French, Latin, Italian for
cross,
>> taking the cross. I think it starts
becoming called that maybe a couple
centuries after
>> couple of centuries after
>> but take me to Europe in that time. Now,
we have covered in our last conversation
the Islamic conquest of Europe and it
was a sweeping chat about basically the
the longforgotten history.
>> We don't need to do it all now, but it's
worth remembering or revisiting
the mood and what it was like in Europe
and the attitudes towards the Islamic
world from the European perspective.
We're talking now, I mean, this is 1095
when the first
>> right
>> crusade is called for by the pope. So in
that period what is the attitude and
beliefs and uh inspiration of Europeans
>> right and u again because I think one of
the problems when talking about the
crusades is there's this deliberate
vacuum not by you but by a lot of
academics and scholars I think it's best
to actually offer a quick recap uh for
those who are not aware of what we
discussed um in depth. So basically what
the the key points to keep in mind is
what we call today the Islamic world
especially the heart of it North Africa
the Middle East or as it's known Mina
okay Middle East North Africa that was
essentially the heart of the Christian
world so it wasn't Europe Europe was
also Christian but Europe was almost uh
you want to call it the little brother
you know the the the newcomer Christian
um and in fact everything north uh
northeast of the Danuban Rine was still
pagan including Scandinavia Yeah. Um, so
that's the context when Islam comes onto
the scene and this is now Christendom
and it's been Christian for centuries.
Uh, it's been it's been Christianizing
since the time of Christ and the
apostles. But then of course it becomes
formalized with Constantine in the four
early 4th century. And now so by time
Muhammad comes on the picture this is
the Christian world. Uh, and he's in
Arabia. So you know there's a systematic
conquest of the Christian West which is
like I mean Mina Middle East which is
all the countries that you can think of
today uh Syria, Lebanon, Israel, the
Palestinian or Jordan, Iraq, Persia too
was conquered and that was its own
empire the Zarastrian Empire and then
all the way north from Egypt to Morocco
all again very Christian heavily
Christian regions all conquered in the
seventh century and then Islams in Spain
in 7-Eleven early 8th century. And it's
at in the middle of France in 732
>> battle of tours. And this is now one
century after Muhammad's death. So
that's a massive change that took place
to the to the globe really to the face
of the old world.
>> I'll say one point on the it didn't make
it yet to Britain. There were Muslim
conquerors of parts of England later but
in 732 bead in his ecclesiastical
histories of England was writing about
the sariss. So it was in the English
imagination that early even before
England existed.
>> Right. Right. And he's uh and he he yeah
he and he does I actually quote him a
fair bit in um in sword and scimitar in
the context of the battle of tours uh
because he he and and it has a prophetic
sort of apocalyptic version how he sees
it as a monk the role of Islam which is
itself a very fascinating topic how
Christians actually perceived the rise
of Islam um and what it meant to them
you know which has a lot to do with
theodysy and God's justice but anyway um
we can maybe look at that later so the
point is uh 7th century you know
Christendom has been split us under and
now you have Europe by itself this is
what historians used to call the
ushering in of the dark ages which is
now a term that many don't like to use
for various reasons but if you look at
the work the pioneering work which has
kind of been suppressed of Henry PN a
French uh historian great historian and
especially his seinal work which is
called Muhammad and Charlemagne
>> and his whole point is that Islam
actually led to the rise of the Middle
Ages and feudalism because it completely
disrupted trade which was ongoing
between Europe and and North Africa and
the Middle East uh because they were one
civilization they were all Christians it
was Christianom and so a lot of so even
the rise of uh you know the knight
culture and the whole structure of you
know feudalism as I mentioned um and the
Frankish empire that's why the book is
called or the his famous line pin is one
census is without ma without Muhammad
there is no charming. So in other words
there was a direct line between these
Islamic conquests and what happened to
Europe. Okay. So now okay now that's the
context and there's and if you look at
the sources this is this was a traumatic
event. Uh the problem is a lot of
historians who may tell you this will
act like they'll give you this most
hygienic kind of neutral rendering and
uh and they'll even cite later Arabic
sources which are essentially
heographies of Islam and it makes makes
it basically look like oh all the
conquered people were begging for the
Muslims to come liberate them from this
or that other oppressor.
>> Okay. And uh and unfortunately too many
western historians go along with that as
well for political reasons. But if you
look at the sources, this was a dramatic
cataclysmic time. I I was recently
reading a writing that is supposed to
come out in 690. This is really I
thought you know most of the conquests
have taken place but now you know Spain
hasn't been conquered yet. Most of North
Africa has but the western part still
has it. And it's uh it's known as Pseudo
Methodius. And it's a very interesting
book and because it actually um
underscored how Christians after him saw
the rise of Islam and they actually
believed that but it's interesting
because it tells you what happened and
how they attacked and it was just it was
the way they're presented is it's not
just that they're violent attackers.
They're a scourge from God because of
Western men or Christian men's many many
sins. And he even lists crossdressing.
Okay, so a lot of them are sexual
immoralities. And that actually is
important because this governs how
Christians for centuries this book
actually as late as uh 1683 when Vienna
was being besieged, they were printing
copies of it to under to make sense of
the Islamic attack on Vienna. So that's
how influential it is.
>> It look inward-looking as if it was
punishment from God.
>> Right. Exactly. And and that really um
colored the way Christians saw this for
the longest time now. So that's the
backdrop and Europe.
>> But just on the backdrop though on the
fear which you or or rather was it fear
was it was there a sense that this was a
an superior military force. Did they h
were they conscious at all about I mean
we talk about let's say be 732 tours
coming up uh the the Muslim conquest
going that far north into France. Did
they uh have a sense that this of what
Islam was or was it just a tribe from
the southern or from the east?
>> Yeah. No, no, no. That early in the 8th
century, Christians do not understand in
any way that this is a new religion. Uh
I mean actually we do have early sources
from people like John of Damascus who's
actually writing in the late 600s. Okay,
so just a few decades after Muhammad,
but he's he's living there in the I
think in Syria. So he's very close to it
and he does understand this is a
religion but of course it's seen as a
false religion and a false prophet uh
who are and tied to biblical prophecy as
an antichrist figure. But in Europe by
and large the the the people of the
seventh 8th and 9th centuries just saw
destruction you know they just saw these
sarens as they called them coming to
destroy and annihilate. However, what's
interesting is they also these the Musl
and this is what kind of underscores
that there is a religious element to it.
They always went out of their way even
in in tours and in this and and that to
denigrate and attack Christian
symbolism. So they would attack
churches. They would break crosses.
Yeah.
>> They would uh you know engage in all
sorts of things. Sous one of the
earliest writers about the earliest
attack uh right around 634. This is
right at the beginning of the Islamic
conquest in the holy land and he was the
patriarch. He also talks about how they
would you know he has this long sermon
about why are they doing this? Why are
they attacking the cross? Why do they
split on spit on our holy images? So
there is uh you know they sense a
religious hostility. They didn't
understand this is Islam. there's a
prophet named Muhammad this and that
that early except for other guys like uh
John of Damascus and others but in the
west it was definitely just seen as
these are just marauders savages come to
destroy with an special hate dislike for
our lord Jesus
>> so sorry just then on on the Muslim
invaders uh there's a fantastic episode
actually on the battle of tours on the
rest of history with Tom Holland and
Dominick Sambrook and they debate the
question whether the invaders themselves
were religiously motivated or whether
they
it was all about loot and power and
conquest and it was maybe some sort of
radical young men but not necessarily
religiously motivated. What what would
what's your answer to that? What
>> that's a great question and um and it
really goes to the heart of a lot of
things including up until now with
modern day terrorists and Muslims. Are
they even religiously motivated or is it
something else? And so um in that
context actually it there's a good
reason to say a lot of them weren't. And
the reason religiously motivated because
um a huge part of that army that invaded
through Spain and went through the p the
Pyrenees and entered into the ones who
fought Charles Martell were Berbers
>> was the leader of Charles Martell to
he's the one who led the the Frankish
army at the battle of Tours
>> um October 10 732
>> and um so the Berbers were recently
converted to Islam from North Africa.
They're the people who live around from,
you know, Libya, Algeria, Morocco. And
actually during their conquest,
[laughter] it's very interesting because
the Muslims would fight them and they
were pretty rebellious. And they had
this w woman warlord or the cahina. She
was this chieftain who's like very
legendary and they put up a staunch
resistance for many years. And they
would do this thing where they would
convert finally and then the Muslims
would leave, but then it would just be a
fake conversion and they'd go back to
their ways. Then they'd come attack him
again. Anyway, by the time of tours now,
they've been converted. Okay, but it's
very clear that it's skin deep and that
at least the army, a lot of them are
just in it. Okay, we're we've converted
nomally. We're on your team. We're
Muslims and now f now now now what now
all we want is the green light to go
attack, kill, and steal stuff. Okay.
Right. Okay.
>> And so, yeah, there's definitely a lot
of room for that. um especially in that
battle and especially in the context of
the Berbers uh because this is a
different group than what we were
talking about earlier which were the
true Arabs from Arabia. Yes. Uh there's
still of course the core leadership is
Arabs uh from that from the Umayad
caliphates at that point later in that
time. But
>> the Arabic sources do show and do speak
about it the historical text in a
religious as a jihad. Okay. But I'm just
so I'm just saying on the one hand of
course the texts can be like I said some
somewhat eographical and and put a
religious veneer on it. But the reality
is all of the jihads no matter what were
very much motivated by just
>> by plunder. It was it was ultimately
just war and conquest and uh you know
enslavement and the rest of it. So you
can't and that's I think the that's the
appeal of it because there there's
they're inseparable and and Allah
doesn't care if you're you're if you're
right with him in your heart as long as
you go fight and win you're good. You
see what I mean? It's a very different
idea and that's why I say even we can
apply this to today because often times
I see um the people who Muslims radicals
who talk about jihad and so forth
they're really motivated by other things
whether it's uh you know taking it
raping women or enslaving women things
like that but the religious element
validates it so it makes them the good
guys so I think what I'm trying to say
is that the creed of Islam is such that
it it a lot of people who men who
gravitated to it were people who are
just uh maybe unsavory sorts, but it it
justified and gave a pious veneer to the
sorts of things they were going to do
anyway. Most men begin losing
testosterone around age 30, bit by bit
every year. And here's the kicker. Even
when your body is producing it, a lot of
it gets bound up by something called
SHBG.
It's like having money in the bank, but
your card doesn't work. That's where
Mars Men comes in. is designed to help
free up usable testosterone. No
synthetics, no needles, just eight
natural, clinically dosed ingredients
like tongat ali, chilagit, vitamin D,
zinc, boron, and more. You will have
steadier energy, better recovery, more
consistency in the gym. You'll feel
sharper and more driven again. It
supports healthy tea levels, energy,
stamina, and it's made in the USA. third
party tested with a 90-day money back
guarantee. So, there's really no risk in
trying it. For a limited time, our
listeners get 50% off for life, plus
free shipping and three free gifts at
mengo tomars.com. Perfect way to kick
off the new year strong. That's
mentomars.com for 50% off and three free
gifts at checkout. After you purchase,
they will ask you where you heard about
them. Please support our work and tell
them our show sent you. Again, that's
menotomars.com.
50% off for life, free shipping, and
three free gifts. Back to then the
Frankish and the Europeans.
There's an argument made by Theodore
Roosevelt or former
>> president from a long time ago um and
who was also a historian and he argued
that had the uh Christians not engaged
in just war then all of Europe and
indeed America might well be Muslim. Um,
so I'd like to get into the I guess the
theology and thoughts and process, the
thought process of the the Europeans and
obviously there's a long time between
that and the first crusade.
>> So I'm I'm sure it's gradual.
>> There's also the concept of just war
which has actually been well established
by St. Augustine a few hundred years
before that. Um,
>> I don't know how best to approach this
uh this development, this theological
development in the mind of Western
Europeans. Um but perhaps the question
would be from tours to the first crusade
at what point do they start saying
actually the issue the the issue is is
Islam rather than just defending their
own lands and we're going to go all the
way to what we now call the Middle East
to defend it or defeat it.
>> So where I left off was just basically
telling you the conqu the seventh
century conquest of North Africa and the
Middle East and into Spain and the
battle of Tors. This is all the Arabs.
Okay. uh the Arab especially the
righteous khalifs as it's called the f
the second one um um Omar and and after
him and uh and then the Umayad caliphate
okay this is where the great Arab
conquests take place now the the pivotal
event between that and the rise of the
first crusade is that a new actor enters
the stage and takes over the mantle of
Islam in fact the mantle of jihad and
that would be the Turks. So the Turks
started being imported. The um the
Abbassad caliphate especially which was
centered in Baghdad which succeeded the
Umayads started to import Turks as slave
soldiers which was a very common
practice uh in Islam and they they also
would do it later to Europeans like the
Janiseries but the uh so they would
bring them in droves and because they
were great fighters at
>> this point the Turks were even further
east.
>> Yeah. Yeah. They're not they're not in
Asia. No, no. Asia Minor now is still
Christian. Still part of the Byzantine
or Eastern Roman Empire.
>> So they would become
>> I'm talking now like the I'm talking now
9th century is when they're being
brought in. Yeah.
>> And turned into fighters. Okay. Slave
soldiers cuz they were great warriors
and they're Islamized. And then before
long as usual happens these slaves turn
over and turn on their masters and take
over. And especially in the context of
the rise of the Seljic Empire. So the
Seljuks, that's just the tribal name of
one of their founder. And um right
around uh you know, this is now the
11th. So now we're talking about uh
maybe 70 years before the first crusade
is when the Seljixs are really starting
to grow in power. Now they now what they
did is essentially created it was it was
déja vu. They created it was a
reminiscence of what happened in the 7th
century, the conquest, but now it began
a new and now it was in Asia Minor
especially. So, and the thing is and the
thing is because it's closer to us in
time and this this is just a normal
aspect of history, things that are close
to us in time and space, we have more
records. So, we have more records of
what actually these Turks did than what
the Arabs did from centuries earlier and
it is some graphic stuff. Okay. Um, this
is contemporary stuff written by people
living at the time. Um, whoever wants to
look into it, one of them would be
Matthew of Adessa and this is an
Armenian. So now at the now now think of
the Asia Minor or Anatolia Turkey today.
Armenia was much larger at the time. It
was greater Armenia. It was essentially
the right the eastern portion of Turkey
and Georgia as well. And um if you look
at the sources, these Turks ran in
running a muck, killing and slaughtering
tens of thousands um of Armenian
Christians and also Greeks because the
western portion of Anatolia is primarily
Greek [snorts] and destroying churches.
And again, very, it's very obvious that
they have the jihadist animus for
Christianity. Uh they capture a cross
and they send it to Baghdad as a trophy.
They drag it in the dirt. They chop the
heads off of statues of Mary, you know,
things that are actually happening today
as well. Um and uh in one city, the
capital
>> today in Europe, by the way, that
happened in Brussels over Christmas.
>> Yeah, that that happens all the time,
you know. I mean they I know they they
they actually reported that one but this
every year cuz I follow what happens
numerous during Christmas and I and even
not Christmas Christian
crosses and statues are defecated
on and and the altars smeared with urine
and all kinds of graphic stuff which
happened back then too. So the
continuity is staggering. But anyway, so
these um Turks are just running them up
and slaughtering. Ani was the capital of
Armenia. It was known as a as a city of
thousand1 churches. Each and every one
of them was pillaged, plundered, and
burned to the ground. Okay? So, when you
talk about the Armenian genocide of the
early 20th century, it actually really
began a millennium before that, because
what I'm talking about is exactly 1,000
years earlier. Um, now that's going on.
And at the same time that that's
happening, [clears throat]
uh, pilgrims from Europe had always been
going to the Holy Land. Okay? And you
know depending on the Muslim uh governor
or you know they would have a deal for
example Charlemagne had a deal with
Haron al-Rashid and basically it was
peaceful they can come and and and um do
their pilgrimage to the holy sites but
they had to of course pay and [snorts]
even then they would get attacked of
course because the mob would rise up for
whatever reason but with the Seljixs
during this time that I'm telling you it
got really bad for European travelers
okay they were constantly being attacked
they would force more money out of them
and when they'd get the money they'd
kick them out and say you still can't go
pilgrimage.
>> Uh and the worst one happened in 1064.
It's widely documented and there was a
German pilgrimage that came uh and you
know they describe a head nun and abbis
was there who was ofly appearance and
they told her don't go it's dangerous
>> and lo and behold they slaughtered
everyone the Turks and gang raped her
and they raped her to death essentially
and then the chronicle writes and they
did this often to everyone. Okay. So
that is what this is the first crusade.
Now we've
>> a reliable source you think.
>> Oh yeah, absolutely.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so this news is it getting all the
way to Western Europe?
>> Yeah, it's getting Okay. So first the
emperor of the Eastern Roman Empire
Empire, the Byzantine Emperor Alexius,
he is dealing with these Turic attacks
on Asia Minor. Okay. And now they're
very close to him in Constantinople. And
he he calls for aid. He's uh he's
actually the main reason. but also
European pilgrims from Europe directly
who are going and pilgrimage are
suffering and reports are reaching
>> Europe as well. So it's those two things
>> and that's and so that's the backdrop of
the first crusade. It was just more of
the usual but an even fiercer form under
the Turks and now for whatever reason
it's funny because there were calls to
crusades before the first crusade. So
one of the most uh you know in 10 in
1009 so this is well over a century
before the first crusade um uh no I'm
sorry it's not it's it's under a century
okay it's about 75 80 years uh the
Egyptian fatimmed khalif hakimah
to prove the b his bonafidees because he
was a shia were actually ruling Egypt
many people don't realize that they
don't realize alar this bastion of sunni
learning was actually built in was a
shia madrasa in its origins. Um, but he
actually systematically, according to
Muslim sources, destroyed 30,000
churches,
>> yes,
>> and synagogues in in Egypt and Syria,
which again shows you how Christian that
area was. And he even destroyed the holy
supplr, which is where every Christian
went for a pilgrimage, which was built
upon where Jesus was believed to have.
>> And remind me what year that was.
>> 1009.
>> 10:09. Okay. Yeah. Gotcha.
>> And at that time, the pope at the time
tried to call for what? A crusade, even
though they never had it. And there was
a lot of anger and a lot of people
wanted to but nothing came of it.
>> Okay. So when the sepa Yeah.
>> the church of the holy sepa is destroyed
that's actually when the first crusade
is called for.
>> No. No. That's that's when they a pope
tried to call for something like a
crusade but it didn't come to pass.
>> And before then though was there not an
idea of crusades against pagans.
Is that is that again am I going to
because later there were crusades
against pagans in the north and Finland.
Yeah. But earlier when let's say King
Alfred was fighting the great heathen
army was that conceptualized the same
way or is that a separate thing?
>> No no no the the crusade idea begins
against Islam and then later morphs
against pagan peoples but in its origins
it's not with King Alfred. There are
again um in hints of it in the in the
8th and 9th centuries for example when
Rome was attacked by Sarris pirates in
um I want to say something like 850ish
uh several popes would call would
basically the whole thing about the
crusades is you know the indulgence that
if you commit and you fight and you die
okay uh it's not that you go to heaven
the whole the way many people also don't
understand the whole indulgence business
it's not like it's basically it was tied
up to the idea of purgatory
Okay. So, you're saved, okay, because
you were baptized and you were, you
know, washed by the by Christ, but
because you sin, you know, the purgatory
idea is there. So, you have to be you
have to suffer through purgatory. Going
in the Crusades, what that did is it
would alleviate the sufferings because
now you're you're doing good. So, that
should take away from the the time that
you're going to suffer in purgatory.
That's all it was. Because a lot of
people have a misunderstanding thinking
it's kind of like, oh, if you go and
fight, you go to heaven. you know, it
wasn't that. It was more about lessening
the sufferings of purgatory, which is
kind of a a Catholic idea. Okay.
>> Okay. So, they tied it into that that
was coming from the pope himself.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> That's what the indulgences were, which
I think, in other words, they're not as
bad as what people think it is, but a
lot of people think it was just kind of
like, hey, you know, go fight and if you
die, you're going to heaven.
>> Okay. So, um, it's worth touching on the
theology here then a little bit because
this is really seems to me
>> radically different from the teachings
of Christ.
>> So, to have a pope
>> going to that length and it's also
radically different from where we are
today and the church uh calling for any
any such thing. [snorts]
>> Um, you know, Christ if you look at his
actions and behavior through the
gospels, it is
>> it is so there is no violence. Uh when
>> except for that thing in the temple in
the whip.
>> Which humans did he hurt in that?
>> Well,
>> he threw up some tables and
>> threw tables. But it says he drove out
the animals and the humans. I I
>> driving out.
>> Yeah. Okay. But but it's an act of
violence. It's not I mean this isn't
passive.
>> Well, how are you finding violence then?
>> I'm making a whip throwing things over
and uh it sounds like he's he's he's
whipping animals and humans out of a
temple. That sounds kind of violent.
It's not exactly passive.
>> If All right. If that's a take, no, I'm
going I'm going with you.
>> Well, let me, you know,
>> I'm not trying to I'm going in in in the
spirit that you're going with, but I am
saying there is that.
>> Well, there's also the famous case when
he's in the garden of Gethsemane and
>> uh Simon Peter smites one of the uh
people coming to take him away and Jesus
says, "Live by the sword, die by the
sword." And heals the person who's had
his ear lobbed off.
>> So, uh Jesus messages is one of peace
and is his whole miss um life it's
healing or his whole mission um time
mission
>> no this is great a great topic
>> so it is drastically different the the
famous piece of scripture that is
brought up is is when Jesus says I've
come uh it's in my sword I bring the
sword and and it's also the case that he
said you know I came here to divide he
doesn't say you know he's not a a softy
and a hippie- dippy um
>> in any in any if if you actually but
>> nevertheless apart from your one case
that he might have been violent at the
temple there is no he's a piece it's the
opposite of violence it seems to me okay
but do you you you should contend
contend that you think
>> no it's not that I contended it's just
uh there's still a lot to unpack about
that um and there's the implicit things
that aren't said that Jesus didn't say
that actually uh formed just war theory
so maybe we should talk about Well, we
should talk about that, right? Because
so just for theory comes up with St.
Augustine.
>> It came before him, but he's he you
know, he's credited with it because he
really formalizes it and kind of
summarizes it in a good way. And you
know, it it always goes back to so let's
let's stay with Jesus and what he said
and did. So when Jesus Okay, so for
example, and and what I'm telling you is
the arguments that Augustine himself
made. I'm I'm just, you know,
summarizing. So basically he would say
things like okay um what what when when
someone comes to Jesus for help or aid
or miracle and and Jesus obliges them it
almost always ends up with go repent
stop doing what you're doing right
there's a call to change your life
because what they were doing is evil
whether it's adultery or I don't know
being a tax collector or whatever. So
then this Roman centurion comes to Jesus
okay and to know what a Roman centurion
is that's basically a man who's got his
hands dipped in blood. Okay. To to be a
Roman soldier, you've killed.
>> To be a Roman centurion, okay, in charge
of a hundred men, yeah, you've you've
been responsible for a lot of bloodshed
and a lot of debt.
>> Mhm.
>> This man comes to Jesus and he wants a
miracle for his servant. Jesus obliges.
Okay. That and then and Jesus has
nothing to say about this man but good
stuff. Yeah. He says, "I haven't found a
man in all of Israel with as much faith
as this man." Because he said because
that man, the centurion told Jesus, "You
don't have to come with me. If you say
he'll be healed, he'll be healed. Okay.
But no, you would think that Jesus who
tells the prostitute to repent and who
tells every sinner to repent, you would
think the least you would do is tell
this centurion, "You need to stop
killing people."
>> I think he does, doesn't he? No, he
doesn't.
>> No, no, he doesn't say anything. I wish
I had a Bible head to
>> No, you're talking about the liberal
Bibles. [laughter]
>> I'm talking about the
>> proliferate in the UK. I'm talking about
the real Bible. So uh [laughter]
um no no he doesn't have a a single word
neg bad about him now and this so this
is what I mean by it's an implicit um
justification for just war that
Augustine and others site because why is
Jesus not is is why is Jesus not telling
this man look at what you're doing
you're a horrible person you're killing
you're you got to you know put the sword
away he who kills by the sword and die
okay and then there's other men who come
to John the Baptist they're soldiers too
and They say, "What must we do to be to
repent?" So, you know, they've killed
people too. They're soldiers. And he
tells them to be content with their
wages and do not unjustly kill someone.
Okay. Again, makes very makes it very
clear that there's room for what we call
just war theory, which is basically war
in defense or in reclamation of stolen
possessions or to defend the innocent.
Okay, those are just two examples, but
there's many more. So you have that but
now you have another one um another
verse that Jesus said. He said uh okay
and this is a very interesting one. This
actually ties to my book. It's the title
of my book. So uh one of the verses in
Luke Jesus uh he tells his disciples
that um and now you know whoever doesn't
have a a sword sell your cloak and buy
one. And the disciples look around and
they say Lord look here's two swords.
And then Jesus says that's enough. Okay.
Now today to modern day Christians what
does that mean? absolutely nothing. It's
just I don't know mumbo jumbo. It just
it means nothing because it can't mean
swords. All right. It actually meant
something very more literal to earlier
Christians especially medieval and
especially crusaders.
>> So this is the title of your book now.
>> The title of my book is the two swords
of Christ.
>> Okay.
>> And um so what how medieval Christians
understood it was that there's two sword
that we as Christians have to be armed
with two swords. One to fight spiritual
evils which I think modern day
Christians will still agree with. and
one to fight secular hum
human human agents evil. Okay, so a
secular sword to fight and a spiritual
sword. That's how it was understood.
Okay, that and again the secular sword
is used in a just war concept, not go
conquer and kill and force people to be
Christians. Okay,
>> and um so to my book, the two swords of
Christ, I call it that in a way because
that because it's about the military
orders and they often would cite that uh
verse and also as a pun. It's I ended up
writing about the two main ones which is
the Templars and the hospitalers. So in
a way they were the two swords of
Christ. And if you see the the the cover
the pommel on each of the two swords
represents one of one of the others one
of the two. Anyway, so you definitely
have and this is I've told you all these
verses. Okay. And there's more. And then
there's the whole Old Testament which
you have to bear in mind for medieval
Christians was very real. They saw
themselves as the successors of the
Hebrews of the Bible. And the Old
Testament is full of violence. The Old
Testament is full of God calling for
violence. Okay? And so they they they
also embibed that tradition in
themselves. Okay? So I think all so all
of that the Austinian concept of just
war, the two swords of Christ logic
which was pretty prevalent at the time
and you know the centurion and all these
different examples the old testament and
its tenor all throughout and then of
course uh what Muslims are doing at this
time and Augustine was writing at the
time that the western empire was under
attack from barbarians and there was the
fall of the western empire to barbarians
in 476 AD. there was a sense of if we
don't defend ourselves and that's this
long before Islam if we don't defend
ourselves actually
>> that's what happens right
>> yeah and then and like and then there's
a human element you know like between
you and me when we talk about it this
idea of ultimate pacifism it's just kind
of hard to understand if you take it to
this logical conclusion okay imagine
okay so Jesus is with us in a room and
um a horde of barbarians burst in and
start raping and mutilating women and
children is Jesus going to be like don't
do anything I don't hurt those guys, but
it's okay for the women and children to
be hurt. Like why? What's the logic in
that?
>> Well, we never have an example like
that. We have the example of Jesus
commanding us to turn the other cheek,
>> right?
>> And there's a wisdom to that.
>> But that that's a personal thing. You
can't have a society like that. That's
my point.
>> And and it would be a sin if someone
tries to rape your daughter. It's a sin
not to do something about But I my point
is I don't think Jesus is saying create
a constitution based on you know the
sermon on the mount because if you do
that you're going to be run down. People
are going to take advantage of you and
they're going to exploit you and they're
going to run you down. Okay? Is that is
that the ultimate message of the gospel?
Um and again I'm not preaching or saying
that Christians need to be militant. I'm
just saying the bare minimum is to be w
you know he he Jesus said be as innocent
as doves but as wise as serpents. Okay.
And uh so on people need Christians are
called to be wise and prudent and it
doesn't you know so to take all these
let's say policies or actions and and
just think your job is to lay down and I
call them doormat Christians and have
everyone walk over you and think somehow
that they're not going to do that. No, I
mean left to its logical conclusion if
Christianity does not defend itself just
like that quote from Teddy Roosevelt
>> which is absolutely right and I quote in
sort of scimitar somewhere and I I have
a paraphrase where he says if Christians
did not know how to fight and parallel
and eventually overcome the Muslims and
he talks about basically from the 7th
century to the 1700s
he's like Christianity would have been
snuffed out because it was snuffed out
in other areas where Islam took over
which is the Muslim world. Okay. Europe
could have been like what the uh the the
cops of Egypt and the Assyrians in in in
Iraq and Syria are experiencing. Is that
is that the ultimate vision you know for
Christ that Christians must always be
attacked and abused and mauled and raped
and uh you know again it's one thing to
say oh Christianity is not about going
on the offensive which I'm for that but
to just say that we have to go out of
our way um you know and and okay I've
actually been looking into this very
deeply this question and I actually have
something important to share with you um
this is a philosophical take on why
people today including you and me
possibly have a problem with violence
and how it seems so uncchristian to us.
Shall I elaborate?
>> I'm all ears.
>> Okay. So, I think what's going on today
[clears throat] is that essentially
modern Christians of today despite what
they think they know or what they
believe are ultimately governed by by a
materialist philosophy just like
atheists. By that I mean, okay. So, what
is materialist philosophy? It's the it's
the philosophy that says I only believe
and act upon and take into consideration
that which is real. Okay, this is real.
You're real. Okay, don't give me so we
deal with physical reality things that I
can be can be measured, seen, felt,
quantified and discussed. All right,
metaphysical that word basically means
that which is beyond the physical which
is everything else which is ideas,
morality, ethics, God himself. These are
all metaphysical concepts. The atheist
tends to reject them. And yeah, I get
the logic because his first premise is
only that which I can see, feel, measure
is real. So everything else falls by the
wayside. Now Christians
>> and the atheist will try to build an
ethic code on top of well-being. This is
like a classic Harris tried to do this
in right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now the Christian
supposedly believes in a host of
metaphysical truisms. All right. And a
lot of these truisms, so for example, I
was looking recently at, for example,
the seven deadly sins, right? Uh pride
and lust and envy and uh sloth and
gluttony and uh what else? I'm I'm
probably missing one. Anyway, and I'm
looking at them and I'm thinking to
myself, you know, that was the heart of
what Christians this these are
metaphysical aspects and this was the
most important thing that Christians
were worried about. And look, you know,
seven deadly sins, what's not there is
death and murder and killing, isn't
>> Yeah.
>> Isn't that interesting? You know why?
Because it's a byproduct of those sins.
It's a byproduct of pride and envy and
um uh you know, greed and that sort of
thing. So my point is
back then in this era that we're talking
about, they were governed by a
metaphysical understanding. Okay. Yes.
They understood killing is bad. Okay.
Murder, of course. Of course, I mean,
it's in the Bible. Murder is bad. I'm
not I'm never arguing that it's not. But
to them, there was a whole host of other
things that were even worse. So, that
killing actually was sometimes seen as a
lesser of two evils. Okay? Blasphemy
against God or desecration of holy
spaces or things that and that's my
point. So, all these things that
actuated those Christians to war don't
make sense to modern Christians because
they're materialists at heart. They
don't to them the only parts of
Christianity. Which is why if you look
at modern day Christians, they care
about things like, yeah, don't violence
is bad. Killing, of course, stealing is
bad. Why? Because it's physical. And
well, what are the virtues? Oh, helping
the poor. Um, helping the needy. Again,
money, it's physical. You're helping
their, you know, you're helping their
material lots of these people. But you
don't hear anymore about moral sins or
moral virtues. And that's because I
believe modern-day Christians, despite
what they say or or they claim to
believe, have been sucked into the
materialist worldview like the atheist.
And so they prioritize the same sorts of
things like violence. Physical violence
is the ultimate evil. Okay? But it
wasn't. So from a a Christian point of
view, physical violence is evil.
>> But there's even greater evils that are
metaphysical and abstract. Okay? And
that's what those guys were fighting
against. And if it meant we have to
fight and kill, then so be it because we
had to guard the soul.
>> Yes.
>> You know, the the sins that I'm talking
about that are abstract um this they
were evil and they were bad because they
affect and kill the soul which is all
that matters because the body is going
to die anyway. Part of just war theory
they would Augustine said that he said
we're going to die anyway. So it's
because you killed someone in in in a
just cause it's not exactly a big deal.
We're all dust anyway. It's the soul
that matters. So that I think and today
you look at our society I talk you know
pride well the the really envy is pride
and envy and lust and gluttony and sloth
those are uh not only are they not
frowned upon in our society they are the
heart of our economy. Okay
>> quite and I think since the great war
and the second world war even honor and
valor are no longer things
they meant so much those words and today
what do they even mean? But probably
because of the physical
>> exactly
>> trauma of those two wars, those who
>> Well, yeah. Yeah, that that for sure.
But I guess what I'm, you know, I'll
wrap it up.
>> Well, I think you're on to something if
I if I might add something. I think part
of the reason historians on the Crusades
seem to do a bad job. It's always very
difficult to find good histories of the
Crusades because they actually can't
even conceptualize what you're talking
about.
>> They anacronize.
>> It's they anacronize. It's it's quite
often done in what the economic
motivations which I was going to ask but
what are the material motivations
because they can't possibly be any other
one and actually spiritual that's why
exactly you're absolutely right this is
[clears throat] one of the problems in
understanding the crusades because they
see it from a Marxist materialist lens
okay and um but [clears throat] I'm
saying it's even worse because
Christians see it that way too which is
why Christians poo poo and condemn the
knights of the temple and the hospitaler
because on the one hand these guys were
pious monks crawling on their knees,
okay? Like literally think of a medieval
monk and then on [clears throat] the
other hand they're at war and they're
just these valorous fierce warriors.
Okay, which you know to us does it's
what a complete contradiction, right?
You're either a doormat [clears throat]
monk who's on the, you know, crying or
you're a fighter. You're not both. So
they were very interesting animal this
fusion and uh and very effective as well
but [clears throat]
like I said they didn't I they were not
materialists. So yeah killing is bad.
We're not going to kill someone
unjustly. But there's so much worse
that's going on that we need to fight on
behalf of
>> morality. Okay metaphysics that which is
beyond the physical. We have to protect
and that's why if we have to fight okay
and kill then so be it. modern day
Christian I don't think gets that
because he is a materialist which is to
say he's an atheist at heart. I think
too many Christians they you know they
just throw out formulations but when you
see the way they live and the way they
see the world it's it's really
indistinguishable from an atheistic
worldview and I think a lot of people
know that deep down inside when they
think about it. So anyway, I tell you
all that in the context of just war, but
also to help make sense of these
crusaders, especially, you know, the the
the Templars and the and the
hospitalers, the military orders. What's
really, you know, amazing about them is,
like I said, really emphasizing, you
know, you had what's called a secular
crusader, which was a a regular European
knight or whatever who would go and
fight who's obviously a Christian, but
these guys were, you know, very pious on
the one hand and very violent on the
other. And uh in my book, I actually
talk about how this even then was seen
as strange amongst some critics, but
others actually thought it was well, you
know, like St. Bernard of Clervau. He
was he was a champion for the Knights of
the military orders. Um and it's very
interesting stuff that like you said is
just completely missed by most people.
>> We actually haven't even properly
started with the crusades themselves
which is what this conversation was
supposed to be about. But there is one
thing I wondered whether it was
important to the um world view of
Europeans at that uh point was the
Constantinople which we touched on in
the Turks going increasingly west.
Constantinople it's still the heart of
Christendom right at this point in in
time it's still the most cosmopolitan
it's the center of the world in um to to
right would that be right understanding
that so the idea of Turks coming closer
to Constantinople
>> was that in a way a motivation being
like actually this is going too far or
or have I sort of speculating here but
>> you're definitely on to something so
first of all in the the Byzantine that
word is was coined in the 1800s. Okay.
So the the people living in
Constantinople called themselves Romans
and the Arabs and the Muslims called
them the Romans. So these were the
Romans both to themselves and to their
enemies. That's there there's no
Byzantine word. Okay? They were the
successors and they really were of Rome.
You know all that changes that
Constantine moved it from Rome to New
Rome as it was called but it took his
name on. He became Constantinople and
the administrative language changed from
Latin to Greek. Okay. Right. But but it
was still Christian and it was still
Rome in their eyes. So that would so
>> but let's say the the Franks and the the
English wouldn't have thought of
themselves as Romans.
>> No no that's the thing that's
>> they thought of themselves as
Christians. Would they have thought this
these are our Christian brothers would
would
>> Yeah. Well before the split which uh I
think is in 11th century. Okay. Right
around the first crusade actually. Not
not so far. But to the lay man these
splits never made sense. I mean these
were always you know
>> this is the split with the Orthodox
>> and the Catholic
>> Catholic which is about 1050 or
something like that. Yeah.
>> And um which is actually a few decades
before the first crusade. Um so before
that it was all really one church more
or less um the business the the or the
eastern Constantinople orthodox and the
Catholics there was really no split at
that point. [clears throat]
So but but at the same time Rome after
it being completely annihilated you have
the pivotal event in the year 800 which
is when the Roman pope crowns
Charlemagne as a as a first holy Roman
emperor. [clears throat]
>> Okay so that brings Rome old Rome as
Catholic Rome back into play and it it
works with Constantinople but there's of
course a little envy and power struggle
between the two as well. Um but not as
you can see not with the first crusade
because the first crusade was all about
helping uh Constantinople. So yeah,
Constantinople was seen especially so
Muhammad himself in a canonical hadith
wanted uh Constantinople and but of
course he calls it Rome you know whoever
whichever Muslim conquers Rome by which
he meant Constantinople uh would get the
greatest rewards in paradise you know
because it was such an important goal
okay for the for Muslims
>> would he he meant the city itself not
the empire or not sort of
>> he he probably meant the uh the city
itself which would would have been the
empire you know in his in his way of
thinking from Arabia, you know, I mean,
it's known as Rome over there, but it's
really big. Yes.
>> Because it encompasses a lot of
territories.
>> They don't capture it until 1453,
uh, which is a long way away in our
history. We should actually get to the
beginning of the crusade, by the way. I
think it's a pretty good uh preface
>> prelude. [laughter]
>> So, uh, take me to 1095. I know your
books about the Knights Templar and
Knights Hospital, but that's that is
actually a bit later.
>> Yeah, they come after the first crusade.
Yeah,
>> let's go to the first crate first
crusade. Sorry, we did talk about this a
little bit in our last conversation, but
it's worth um recapping then. So, we've
got a sense of the world view of these
uh knights and warriors and fighters. Um
and this is the people's crusade first
and foremost, right?
>> Well, yeah, there's a Well, okay. So,
Pope Urban in 1095 in Claremont calls
for what became the first crusade. And
you know, it's supposed to be one of
these big conundrums in history because
like I told you, there were calls for
earlier crusades including when they
destroyed the holy supplr in 109 and
they never materialized. This one for
for whatever reason just snowballed all
over the all of Europe. Uh that in fact
that more than they even wanted started
going on crusading. Okay. Okay. And the
first uh ones were the peasants, the
peasant crusades who just were, you
know, a bunch of rabble who, you know,
it would have been better for them to
just stay home because they engage in
all sorts of atrocities. This is when
the Jews of course get attacked along
the Rine. Um and then
>> this is a terrible program, by the way.
10 to sort of 12,000
uh Jews killed
>> probably. The numbers are Yeah, they're
pretty big. And but again, you know,
they did it of course the those
Christians uh but it was not sanctioned.
It was not. In other words, they would
get excommunicated because of that. They
would be they would be condemned by the
church authorities.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> So, why do they think that why do they
think that the Jews were
should be thought as well? It's just
anyone who's not a Christian.
>> What happened is a lot of these peasant
crusaders were sort of motivated by
million millionarianism which was rife
at the time. Okay. Which is
>> it's this idea that that Jesus is
coming. It's the end of the world
because it's almost the you know it's
the year 1000. It's it's the 11th
century and up before that also
>> the nearly the year 1100.
>> Well, yeah, but I mean before that there
was a lot of that kind of movement going
on and a lot of these guys were almost
like uh like portrayed themselves as
prophets but but the whole point was
okay so we're marching all the way to
fight you know Muslim Jew to them same
thing they're Christ.
>> So they did think Yeah. Christ and I put
them in the same
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and the logic would be
kind of like why are we marching and
killing ourselves for thousands of miles
when here they are amongst us. Okay?
Right?
>> Which was not of course the purpose of
the crusade and that's why they were
attacked and executed and and and often
times the people who protected them were
the church. The Jews would run to church
authorities um who would actually help
and protect them. So it was an it was it
was a bad move obviously and they were
condemned for it and um a lot of it I
think was just repacity trying to just
take the money and like an easy way to
an easy target you know.
>> Okay. So they had material
>> objectives as well. It's not solely
spiritual.
>> Yeah. And you know and they reached and
and they got their just desserts in a
way because the these the peasant
crusaders were the first to set off.
They did that. Um it was mostly under
one guy um I forget his name who was
like a real rabble rouser. Um, and
anyway, and then they go into the heart
of the Islamic world before everyone
else and they come annihilated. Okay,
just completely annihilated because
they're just rabble. Okay, they had no
they had no knights, no military order.
It's just a bunch of wild crazy people
running around with pitchforks
attacking. I mean, this is the these
were these were the lowest of the low IQ
types, okay? I mean, they were they were
enthusiastic. This is kind of like, you
know, the I don't know. I don't want
>> captured by a religious fever.
>> Captured by religious fervor. Um, and
they were like, they're going to give up
their lives, right?
>> Were their lives good?
>> Well, no.
>> Pretty awful, I imagine. So, they're
like, "F this."
>> Yeah. F this. I'm traveling. And then,
you know, oh, look at this rich
comfortable Jew. And then they rile each
other up about it. And, oh, well,
they're the Christ killers, too. And
then, you know, before you know it, you
get a pogram.
>> Okay.
>> So, they go, they march across Europe.
This presumably a few months.
>> Yeah. They're the first to have set off
the peasant crusade, the people's
crusade as it's called. And uh they
they're the first to go and they just
all they do is chaos and then they end
up they meet
>> they meet the Turks in Asia Minor,
right? On the other side of
Constantinople,
>> right? And once they get there, they
just get annihilated. So it's almost
like a just dessert type thing. Um
>> so they don't get much further than
that.
>> No, they they they make no progress or
no um gains or anything. It's they just
get killed.
>> Okay. This is 1095, right? So
>> um
>> Well, it's probably it's probably now
early 1096.
>> 1096. And but so this isn't the first
crusade as we as it's called as
historians call it. The historians
>> this is the f it's a part of the first
crusade was mass movements that went in
different waves. This is the first one
>> and this was the worst one and it was
the most ineffective one. Okay. It was
just the one that like we said it it it
did not accomplish any goals and it just
created havoc and killed Jews.
>> Okay. Um and then
so is the next one a more solid what
what happens next? Do do Europeans learn
about the the pe the quotequote people's
crusade? What what what's the the story
that gets home
>> most? Okay. So you you have the people's
crusades who are peasants. Then you have
the nobles and the knights. Okay. They
they take their time preparing because
they know this is war and they know war
requires logistics and supplies, you
know, and that's the whole difference
between the peasants. They just
religious fervor and they run out with
pitchforks and uh after they get tired
realize, oh boy, we're not even a tenth
of the way there. Well, let's just get
them, you know. Okay, so these guys,
they basically wash their hands of the
peasant crusaders. They have nothing to
do with them. Okay, these are
professional warriors. These are knights
and their men at arms and so forth. So,
various ones of them raise large large
armies. And it's very interesting
because it goes against what you know, a
lot of modern historians will tell you
for the longest time. I think it's uh
Sir Steven Runsman who wrote, I think, a
three volume well-loved history of the
>> which I read in between our two
conversations.
>> Okay. Yeah,
>> you were probably then familiar with the
term second sons, which is his way of
saying that a lot of the men who went on
crusading were second sons who did not
have any inheritance because of
primogenitor. And so they their idea was
I'm going to go to this foreign land and
carve my own kingdom.
>> Again, right,
>> material
it wasn't just spiritual. It was a
combination.
>> Well, well, it's material in the eyes of
Runsmen because he's a materialist,
>> right? But what I'm saying is when you
look at the sources actually that's been
disproven and other historians have said
no that is not the consideration because
the vast majority of them actually were
landed and gave up everything and sold
and gave away you know the vast majority
>> Yeah. Yeah. Godfrey uh of Buon and uh
Raymond of Tuloo and um there's others
in my book you can see them um and they
weren't necessarily and some were second
son some were third some were first uh
but they were always it wasn't about
material considerations even though
that's become such an ironclad idea in
our mind but a lot of uh you know more
academic historians have done a lot of
ground work to show that that idea is
just completely wrong based on the
sources that I'm telling you I'm just
giving you a summary okay that that was
not really a consideration
And think about it. You're
people really forget how hard what these
crusaders were doing. You know, you're
you're you're traversing all of Europe.
You know, most of them are coming, let's
say, from Frankie or France, and you're
traveling thousands of miles on foot,
okay? And to get to this with armor,
>> with armorapons, and you're going into
enemy territory. And uh you know, if it
was about just conquering a piece of
land, there's easier ways to do it
>> than that. You know what I mean? Yeah,
the the whole pagan north could still be
conquered and even justified and say,
you know, you're pagans. That's not what
they were doing at that time. They were
doing this. So,
>> but but some but they were there were
some of them were good at it. Right. So,
we're talking about this period of the
Normans and the Normans were
successfully conquering.
>> Yeah. They were in Sicily. They actually
had conquered it from Arabs and Muslims.
The Normans definitely played a major
role in the Crusades both.
>> When did they when did they conquer
Sicily from the Arabs? Uh I want to say
um it was actually relatively early like
not not long before the crusades maybe
in the in the 11th century I think the
early or mid 11
>> would that have been considered a
crusade [sighs and gasps]
>> not really
>> they didn't uh yeah that term had still
or or that concept had still not uh
solidified it was you know it's in the
air
>> not the word crusade but was it like
recaptendom is what is more
>> yeah yeah it was of course it was seen
as a a reclamation for christrysendom
from the sariss you know but I mean you
know the whole panopoly of theological
justification and all that may not have
coalesed at the point at that point yet.
>> Okay, that really starts with the first
crusade and it continues actually
codifying with subsequent subsequent
crusades.
>> Okay, but um
>> where were we?
>> Okay, so you you've you've got this army
that uh going all the way to you've had
the disastrous people's crusade and
you've got the the actual warriors, the
professionals uh uh coming along. You've
you've painted a
despite having painted actually the
world view of these people there's
there's if I were to ask them one of
those crusaders the warrior ones for the
sort of elevator pitch
>> for why obviously they would know what
an elevator is but what you know what is
the kind of brief reason why is it to
reconquer the holy land from the Muslims
is that what they would have said
>> it would have been there were two chief
reasons the chief reason was because
okay and this is another idea that's
hard for us to understand um holy land,
holy places, sacred sites. Okay, the
holy land uh where okay Jesus and the
apostles and the patriarchs of the old
testament that whole area is so
important to modern day Christians they
don't get that you know oh g is
everywhere Jesus is in me I don't know
who cares okay you know that's the mo
that was completely alien at that time
at that time it was just it was not
unlike Jews and Muslims today who are
you know fanatical about the holy land
uh Christians were just as well and so
you had unbelievers Muslims who were
desecrating the holy land where Christ
walked and he was incarnated and where
God was incarnated and resurrected and
I'm giving you the way they would talk
and now it's being completely all this
sacrilege is happening at the hands of
these unbelievers and on top of it
they're killing Christians and they're
preventing them from pilgrimage. So that
was the chief reason was now it's time
we need to go and take charge of matters
and and and uh and and the second one
was to help fellow Christians. And so in
a way the the one verse in the Bible
that says where Jesus says you know the
two greatest commandments is to love God
with all your heart and then love your
fellow man. That's in their mind what
they were doing because the loving God
was to go and protect his sanctity in
the holy land which was being desecrated
and loving your fellow man was to go
help the fellow Christians who were
being also attacked. Right. They were
loving their brethren.
>> So that Yeah. It was actually seen like
a a great act of love despite how it's
seen now today as a cynical move to go
for second sons to go and carve out a
kingdom.
>> Right. Okay. So
this this second batch of warriors, they
make it
>> they do make it
>> to the Holy Land.
>> Yeah.
>> And how does that go? Well, I mean,
first of all, [clears throat] it's it's
very dramatic when you look at the
sources and I I get into in Defenders of
the West chapter one, I I really focus
on that and just getting there, you
know, and this is this is this is an
important point when um at some point
you should ask me, you know, so are the
remind me say, "So, are the Crusades
glorious or not?" Because I'm going to
I'd like to because a lot of people like
to tell you, "Oh, the Crusades are a big
failure." And yeah, they are in the end,
but you you miss the real point. And
I'll get into that. But so they cross
and they go through hell, okay? I mean,
the the the sufferings they go through
before they even start fighting, okay?
Starvation, sickness, that, you know,
plague,
>> okay? And everyone around them is an
enemy. Nobody's helping them because
they just threw themselves into the
lion's den. Okay? And there's few
Christians.
>> But miracle of miracles, as it was seen,
they prevail. First they conquer um
Adessa and then Antioch uh which was
this was the long this is probably the
most prolonged and kind of epic siege of
the whole first crusade. Took like well
over a year and uh very very uh dramatic
story and then finally it culminates
with the conquest of Jerusalem I think
around July 15 uh 1099. Okay. Okay.
>> So the those crusaders the real
professional crusaders really start
their trek in 1097 and by 1099 it's
accomplished. Okay. those two years,
those two brutal years. Okay. Um and and
they went and uh they they accomplished
what they set out to do. They carve a a
kingdom christryendom. A little
christryendom. Uh outreamer as it was
known. You know, out
>> out what?
>> Outreamer.
>> Outreamer. Yeah. What does that mean?
>> It means the the Christian kingdom on
the other side of the ocean basically.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Um and and it was uh so like I
said it was principalities and
territories and the kingdom of Jerusalem
was the heart of it and uh that's it.
They hold on to it peace they lose peace
by meal uh by peace meal various they
lose Jerusalem in um 1187. So under
>> you're jumping ahead. Yeah. Okay. Uh um
do we have a sense of how many were
killed not just of the crusaders but of
those who were in the holy land that
they were attacking?
>> Yeah. Uh so yeah the numbers so first of
all again the numbers is always an issue
because the primary sources say one
thing and then modern scholars will tell
you no no it can't be that but the
numbers according to the sources are
literally hundreds of thousands but this
would include women and children. Okay
>> so they were slaughtering Muslim women
and children. No, no. Women and European
women and children would go on the first
crusade.
>> They went with them.
>> Yeah.
>> Because the intention was to stay there.
Yeah. And to build
>> to take over and uh you know,
>> so it was warriors at the front with
with the families behind
>> and sometimes just Yeah. I mean, it I'm
I'm possibly conflating uh the peasant
crusade with the professional crusades,
but even the professional crusaders,
it's known they had women and children.
It was just these were what they were.
The crusades, what you have to
understand, were armed pilgrimages.
That's how they you have to understand
them. They were pilgrimages, but now
there were armed. And not only are we
armed, we're taking the offensive to the
people who have been attacking us.
>> So that's exactly when we use when we
were talking about the word crusade and
what it means.
>> So that's actually important because as
as you've already said earlier in this
conversation, doing the pilgrimage had
become not it was fairly normal part of
European life. It would have been
expensive. So presumably it wouldn't
have been peasants doing doing it,
right? It would have been the wealthier
classes or or was it more normal than
that? Was it was there a kind of harsh
version for Christians?
>> No, no. The the pilgrimage was always
there and a lot of it was uh sometimes
as a form of penance. Okay. Because uh
you've done something bad in life. Uh a
penis penance would be imposed on you uh
to go and suffer because to do the
pilgrimage everyone knew you're going to
suffer and possibly die. Okay. So, it
was uh but it was also a holy thing, you
know. It was it was noble. It was
honorable, but get ready for some
action. You know, you might not make it
and it was understood as that. Uh, but
like I said, it was always going on um
until and so so but these first
crusaders, that's the best way to
understand it. You know, we were talking
about the term and what how it was
understood. It was actually understood
as a mass pilgrimage, which is why it
was full of women and children. Okay.
>> Interesting. Okay. So, now we finally
come to the Knights Templar. finally
>> which is founded in 1119 right
>> and this is the topic of your book of
course so
>> to someone who has no idea what the
Knights Templar is what they were why
were they founded who are they what what
is it
>> sure okay so the kingdom of Jerusalem is
now conquered um or as the Christians
see reconquered um and it's under
Christian Latin crusader rule
and now now the a new problem poses
itself okay they've created this enclave
and it's safe It's secure because you
have it's a kingdom. And now more
pilgrims than ever are coming because oh
our our brothers are there and they've
already created a little niche for us.
They have Jerusalem. Okay. So now you
get a big ma a burgeoning mass of um
pilgrimage. But guess what? All around
these kingdoms are still Muslims. All of
them smarting from what just happened.
[laughter]
Okay. Being beaten and being ousted and
and losing, you know.
>> Yes. I'm sure they thought it was
hilarious, Raymond.
>> Yeah. Well, no, no. My point is, my
point is they're waiting for vengeance.
And so these European pilgrims who come
get mauled. It's it's even worse than
before. On route. On route. Exactly. So
yeah, once you get to Jerusalem, you'll
be safe or or
>> And they're still traveling walking
across Europe.
>> Yeah. and and oftentimes sailing um and
uh and they'd go to the port of Jaffa,
for example, and then the fortress of
Ascalon, which was this massive fortress
run by Muslims, would always once the
Christians would go in a in a narrow
defile, they would just come out and
attack and kill them.
>> And Jaffa was at that point not
Christian or was it Christian? Did the
Christians take Jaffa?
>> Yes.
>> Okay,
>> they did. But Ascalon, which was nearby,
was
>> further south. Okay. Um so uh these
you have now all the
>> the pilgrimage is going full full force
>> and so the Knights Temple what what is
this? So what happens is a man Hugh okay
Hugh of Payes I think it's pronounced
pines or pains p a y ns a Frenchman he
actually
>> a ye ns I think
>> yeah yeah
>> well I've seen both but anyway yeah
>> um he's a French crusader who actually
fought in the first crusade went back to
France and then decided to come back to
the holy land settle permanently and he
was according to the sources just
devastated by what was happening to
pilgrims okay and so he and another
knight um by the name of Godfrey Godfrey
from St. Homer, I believe, and another
he another knight, we only know this
other knight's name, Dfrey. And for a
total of nine knights, so they found
seven other knights, created a band of
brotherhoods, a brotherhood who was just
dedicated to escorting pilgrims to to
prevent them from being mauled. Okay?
And just seven men, seven knights. And
um and they called themselves the uh the
the the poor fellow soldiers of Jesus
Christ. And again, look at that. fellow
soldiers of Jesus Christ. Think of the
idea you know Jesus Christ I'm a soldier
like he's a soldier okay uh that was
common to them and uh they were actually
so in 1019 is when they initially form
and they get the blessing of you know
the patriarch there and the king at the
time who I believe is Baldwin I gives
them uh temporary residence in in well
what's what they thought was Solomon's
temple but it's also okay and that's how
they got the name the templars because
they they're head they're the knights of
the temple right and then 10 years later
I mentioned St. Bernard of Clervau he's
a very important figure he actually very
much justifies and rationalizes
including from theology and he talks
about the two swords of Christ like I
told you the one secular and the one uh
spiritual
>> sorry just one point the Alexa mosque
that was built on King Solomon's temple
>> right
>> and uh were the Muslims were cleared out
at that point so right they left the
mosque or
>> yeah would have been but to the
Christians the mosque was still the
temple
>> right right okay the temple called it.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> And there's some theories that that
maybe they were actually somewhere else.
But let's stay with the normal, you
know, interpretation which is that okay,
the aluxa/temple.
And anyway, uh so St. Bernard very
important figure we this guy was, you
know, I mean he's like the most
important cleric and theologian of his
century, you know, the 12th century. And
he was just a fanatic about the military
orders. And he wrote so much. he
promoted. He wrote a I I quote it
extensively in my book. It's called um
the new knighthood and uh where he talks
about you know enough of knights
fighting for gain and worldliness. It's
time for them to be monks and to be
warriors of God. Okay. And he you know
long treatises that he writes. All of
this 10 years later after 119 1129 um at
a council of Troys they become
formalized and they get as an order and
they become history's first military
order. So there were all kinds of
Christian orders up until then this was
the first actual military order which
was a new thing. Okay. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> And uh it got the pope's blessing and so
forth and their their attire was to wear
white which was symbolic of their purity
because they're trying to live pious
Christian lives as monks. And a few
years later they also got the red cross
as a badge meaning their willingness to
be martyed on behalf of Christianom on
behalf of Christ on behalf of
Christians.
>> So actually now when we see let's say
English football fans wearing the sort
of male with the white sheet and the red
cross that is
the word it's it's associated now with
you know St. forge. Um and uh because of
some sort of conflation, but it really
starts with the Knights of the Temple.
Um and uh anyway, so that's the rise of
the Knights of the Temple. And what was
it for? Because okay, we've already
conquered Jerusalem, but the war is
still raging. We're still surrounded by
enemies, Muslim.
>> It wasn't just protecting uh uh pilgrims
who were coming in and out. It was also
Were they trying to increase their
territory when they were there?
>> No. No. They were their primary purpose
in the beginning was just to protect um
pilgrims but very soon they essentially
morphed into doing that but also being a
elite commando force dedicated to
fighting Islam and I think the logic
became if we want to protect Christians
well we then we are in de facto war with
Islam because Muslims are always going
to attack. So in other words, it became
often times, you know, let's preempt
this instead of waiting until Christians
get attacked or then we would so
whenever there would be a war in this
early era and um a crusader king would
would go to war against this or that
Muslim leader, they would be right at
the front.
>> Okay. But firstly, from the Muslims
point of view, the Alexa mosque is the
third holiest site. So this is regard I
mean I'm sure the other territory losses
would have been an offense and those
killed would have been a huge offense
but losing the Alexa must have been for
them.
>> Yeah, you know there must have been a
terrible reaction to that. Right.
>> The the Alexa mosque and the dome the
golden you know the dome on the rock.
Remember these were built specifically
in a way to look down at the holy
supplr. Um those those particular
buildings were built by a khalif in the
uh uh late 8th century I want to say. Um
yeah and the inscriptions around them
are all hostile especially to
Christianity. So around the dome of the
rock which is right adjacent from Axam
mosque. It has all these the Quran
verses which say all God does not have a
son. God is not one of three. You know
infidels are they who say God is uh you
know infidels are they who say Jesus is
anyway. So my point is uh in as much as
it was important to Muslims that that
region it was also seen uh it was
created in a way as a sort of
superiority to Christianity which it had
supplanted. So it was doubly offensive
that it was now retaken by Christians in
that sense.
>> Okay. and the um
crusaders themselves uh were they
splitting into separate kingdoms there
at this point or is this is this is that
later?
>> Yeah. Well, uh eventually well right
from the beginning you had you know
counties and principalities and uh and
kingdoms the kingdom of Jerusalem being
the most notable. Um but they worked
together you know they weren't like
enemies. It's because they because they
were conquered pe in peace meal. So like
I said, Adessa was the very first one I
think in maybe 1098 and it was by uh by
Baldwin the first, you know, and then
later and then Antioch was taken by
Bohem. Okay. And then finally the rest
of the crusaders took Jerusalem and uh
Godfrey was elected the first uh you
know the protector as it was and then
other kingdoms Muslim regions fell and
someone else took them. So they all
worked together but they were their own
independently ruled you know they all
had their it was still feudalism
feudalism had moved to the Middle East
you see
>> right um so back to the Knights Templar
it isn't the 12th century that temple
churches built in London and uh
it's I think it's based on the church of
the holy separate it's a very different
type of building which still stands
today I think it might have got hit in
the second world war by some German
bombs but um uh and as a side point by
the Okay. Hanzimma used the organ in
that temple for the uh soundtrack to
Interstellar, but that's very much a
cycle obviously. Uh but is the fact that
that temple church exists in London
suggests to me that there's they're
going back and forth. There's a there's
a kind of
a kind of route there. It becomes a new
uh
>> Yeah. What happened after after the
council that I mentioned in 1129 where
they became formalized is the Templars
popularity exploded all throughout
Europe and they got tons of don this is
you know the the whole you know myth
that they're so rich which is true they
were very rich because they got so much
in donations by lots and lots of
Europeans were very um they were very um
inspired by this particular military the
only military order so they they got don
nations, lands, uh, money and this is so
that would explain what what's also
happening as distant as England, you
know, from the Holy Land and uh, what
they would do is they would create
precepties or commanderies all around.
So that temple in London that or England
you're talking about, that's what it was
>> where they would have basically bases
all throughout Europe um, to raise money
and to raise recruits and to train them
and to send them to the Holy Land. So it
was like a continuous supply. Okay. And
a lot of And they also had them on the
route uh to the Holy Land as well.
>> Mhm.
>> And it's probably good right now to
actually bring in the hospitalers
because uh
>> this is the night's hospitals, right?
>> Yeah. The nights of the hospital. So
they're as I always say, they're older
and newer. So that so the the the
hospital had existed and this is another
interesting story. It goes back to um so
this goes back to the times of uh
Charlemagne and Haron Rasheed the
Abbassad caliphate who are said to have
good relations and uh because actually
according to Charlemagne's biographer
the only reason Charlemagne wanted to be
so friendly with Muslim leaders was so
he can lessen the yoke on the Christian
subjects of these Muslim leaders. Um so
at any rate at during that time the
supple the holy supplicer is there and
pilgrims are coming and sometimes being
abused and having nowhere to sleep. So a
small hospice formed that uh Haron
Rasheed um permitted and that
Charlemagne had funded. Okay basically a
hospice meaning Christians come you can
serve them you refresh them give them a
place to sleep. Not a hospital but a
hospice. Okay. Even though it's called
hospital. Um
>> so this is in the century. Yeah, this is
the beginning of it is in the yeah 9th
century and then you know with the
vicissitudes of time and the rise of the
Turks it disappears for a while but then
it starts coming back because the holy
supplr is still there after it was
destroyed in 109 by the way it was
rebuilt um Christians the eastern the
Byzantines had to rebuild it a smaller
version but so another hospice grows
there it's by the it's founded by these
Amalfi Italian merchants
>> um right around 1050
Okay. And it's uh and it's again it's
abused and attacked but it exists to
offer whatever um you know sucker to
Europeans. Um and in fact one of the
earliest one was for women because men
would come and visit the monks and stay
with the monks but there would be women
and they're not going to let women with
the monks. So they actually the first
hospice was for women. Okay. And then it
got popular and then they made another
one a hospital for men. Okay. Now it's
it's just a hospice and this is why the
knights of the hospital the hospitals
are even more interesting to me as
you'll see because these are people who
were so committed to serving men mankind
you know uh they give the shirt off in
their codes the way they they they talk
about the sick as our the the sick are
lords okay so they're they were very
much actuated by Christ when he would
say you know if you do this that or the
other thing to the least of me my
brethren you've done it to me
>> so that's why they were, you know, given
over to very altruistic deeds, helping
their fellow man, the the Christian
pilgrims. So, [clears throat] they would
do all that and um, you know, go through
the violence here and there, outbursts
by the Seljics and whatnot. And, uh, and
then finally when the first crusade
comes, uh, in 1099, so now it's in
Jerusalem and the the one the the man
who's, you know, he's he's called
blessed Gerard. Okay. Um he was he was
the head abbott of the hospital and
supposedly you know they kept him the
Muslims they kicked all the Christians
out when the first when the siege began
when the crusaders came
>> as possible fifth column
>> the Muslims kicked all
>> kicked all the Christians out but they
kept him because he would always because
he was good enough to help serve anyone
in the hospice he would serve Muslims
and Jews and whoever so he wouldn't
discriminate um anyway they kept him
there and he becomes the sort of the the
the kind of the founder the name
remembered with the hospital and then so
they conquer it uh the the Christians
the crusaders and now the hospital
starts to grow. All right. But then
before long, what happens is another
right around the time of the Templars,
another shift starts happening in the
hospital where they realize that why are
we just sitting by doing nothing and
waiting for Christian pilgrims to get
mauled and then we have to take care of
them and try to heal them and try to
bring them back to some semblance of
life. Why don't we go on the offensive
to prevent it from happening? Okay, so
it is they slowly become militarized.
Okay. And
>> so what is this is of the sort of what
kind of period are we talking from from
the arrival of the crusades in in 1099
in Jerusalem
>> to
>> it starts getting militarized under the
second uh master of the hospital Raymond
of Pu. Okay. And uh this I want to say
so Gerard the one I told you dies very
early after the first crusade maybe uh
maybe something like uh 11 1110 or
11:15. Okay. And then this guy Raymond,
so he's the one who's credited with
militarizing it. But it's a very slow
process. It's not like overnight they
become militarized. And it it starts
like I would say between 1120 late 1120s
and until right around 1160s when you
finally have definitive proof that they
are now on the war path fighting. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> But it goes slowly and slowly. But now
what I find very interesting is uh is
this the the combination okay of who the
so the hospitalers start off as these
people these altruists who are just
committed to helping their fellow man
okay they're nurses essentially okay and
um they give them their bed they feed
them they you know clean and dress their
wounds they bathe them okay this is the
kind of guy the man they are and at the
same time that same Christian who you
can't even find today become became a
ferocious warrior. Okay, which is kind
of a an interesting conundrum again from
our mentality. It's hard to but for them
it makes sense. Like I said, on the one
hand, why am I always going to why wait
and let Christians get killed and mauled
when I can actually do something to
protect them? Okay.
>> And uh and if I do love my man the way
Christ commands me to, why would I sit
by idally when I know they will be
raided and attacked? So they became like
the Templars and they started be being
escorts um and guiding pilgrims uh just
like the Templars. So I think even more
than the Templars, the hospitalers
really underscore
how you know these two seemingly
different uh virtues if you like which
is extreme piety and the kind not just
piety but love of serving fellow man
with violence. Okay. Um again is that
it's it's like seeing a nurse who's
dedicated to war. Right.
>> Right. In our modern kind of parlance.
Um but that's what they were. But
>> to what extent was it necessity? I mean
exactly it was a certain point they
don't have a choice. They actually have
to defend themselves.
>> And then which goes back to our you know
earlier conversation about just war. Um
I think if Jesus was there he would
understand and agree
>> because it would have been relentless
attacks from
>> right
>> you know it's kind of like uh and
especially in the context of you know
the centurion and he didn't tell him to
quit the army even though this man was
killing people
>> and and the Roman centurion was probably
probably not involved in just war
because Rome was a expansive power
expanding and conquering. Okay, I expect
Roman centurions were killing people for
not necessarily just causes and he still
didn't uh you know condemn him. So
surely for protecting our fellow man
>> but let we don't need to reh I don't
think he condoned him either uh
>> well he he did praise him
>> but not for
>> his faith
>> he praised him for his faith
specifically. What was the relationship
between the Templars and the
hospitalisters? Were they in contention
with each other? Well, in origins they
were separate orders. Um, they very much
learned to work together. In fact, in
their statutes, uh, you know, a Templar,
for example, had to fight to the death
until the Templar, uh, the banner came
down. But if it came down and the
hospitaler nearby was up, he'd go there,
uh, and fight with them. Okay? And the
same vice versa. So, they did have sort
of a a close, you know, I mean, they
were their own brotherhoods, but they
were still very much worked together.
And oftentimes when a crusading army
would march so they became the backbone
of all the crusading armies which were
run by kings you know king Richard and
his men uh or whoever and they would
often one would take the v would be at
the vanguard and one would be in the
rear okay one would protect so they were
so even uh even in a crusading army they
were still pro they were the protectors
of the of the marching pilgrims because
that's what remember crusaders are so
they would protect the rear and the
front and they were they were wherever
the fighting was thickest. They were
there
>> and were they what would they have
considered themselves? Would they have
been sort of Frankish and Germanic
backgrounds? You mentioned Richard
there, but this this is a little bit
later I think right this is the third
crusade.
>> Um these early European men it's more f
French German
>> the word yeah the word and it's kind of
hard too especially when you look at the
Arabic sources because for from the
Arabic point of view they're all Franks.
We still have that word in the Arabic
language. is even colloquialized
>> which just could mean European stuff
from that point.
>> Today if you're speaking Arabic if I say
he's a fangi I mean he's a European.
Okay. So but yeah by and large most of
them probably came from what we would
call modern day France but it was the
Normans as well. It was uh you know uh
the Germans. It was Italians.
>> Okay. A lot of Spaniards would have
wanted to go but they were involved in
their own crusade. And actually more
than one pope would ban them from going
on that crusade because they had their
own crusade in Spain.
>> Right. Okay. So um we we've got to this
period now where the Christians the
crusaders are have some sort of control
in the holy land. We've got the Knights
Templar and the hospitals who have sort
of come up and are this kind of uh
special forces uh for them. And you
still have new crusades coming, right?
If I can fast forward a little bit
>> 1147 and I've understood this to be the
second crusade and the ordering is a bit
or the names of these crusades is a bit
complicated to me if you include the
people's crusade but this is Eugene II
um again this is and it's more Frankish
and Germanic crusades
>> I want us to eventually get to uh the
fourth crusade which is in my
understanding like a disaster Christian
on-Christian nightmare We'll we'll do
past then another time. But I think this
this sort of 200 per year period of
rule.
>> Um can you take me to the next crusades
and the relevance of significance and
and what what we understand about those?
>> Right. Okay. So the second crusade uh it
takes place what what initiated is is
Christmas day 1144.
Adessa, the oldest county that was
actually rec conquered by Baldwin that I
mentioned to you was sacked on Christmas
Day by this uh by his name is Zeni uh
basically an adab or a Turkish warlord
and the you know the atrocities are just
beyond horrific and they're widely
recorded and uh and the thing is a lot
of people don't realize this but Adessa
at this time was mostly Armenians and
Syriak Christians
and the ruling elite for the Franks.
Okay, but they all got killed. The
patriarch, you know, I mentioned to you
Matthew Vadessa as a a very important
historian of the of the crusading era.
He was actually there and he got killed
uh you know by the Turks. Anyway, so
that propelled the the second crusade.
>> Okay.
>> That sack.
>> And so that news again, same story
again. News gets back to Europe,
outrage.
>> Exactly. uh Christian sort of unity
people pick up arms and they you know
they do what they consider to be
honorable to go over there and are they
successful do they
>> no this one is a complete disaster they
and and there's various reasons why but
um you know it's hard to even get into
what but this is also where like the
Templars you know show their stuff
because they're still small at this time
this is 11:44 a little after 11:44 and I
told you they were formalized 11:29 and
So, they're still a small group, but
they actually um I don't want to make
this about the Templars, but even it's
it's an unmititigated disaster. And a
lot of it has to do with poor strategies
and logistics on the Christians part.
And um and a lot of it also according to
some is because they thought they they
were trying to live off the legacy of
the first crusaders who were basically
their great their forebears, great great
grandfathers and uh who were seen as so
heroic. So they they wanted to kind of
live through that, but they just I they
didn't have their metal apparently and
um they just completely it was very like
I said poor strategy and just uh and and
bickering between the leaders and all
that sort of thing. So nothing
whatsoever was gained with the second
crusade. Uh except like I said it's the
Templars start coming into their own and
you can see how people including the
kings the French king at the time um
Louis the 7th yeah he actually really
relied on them in many ways even though
they were still a small new force. Okay.
And then um so this is really the story
after the first crusade it's all
downhill. Okay. Um now between the
second crusade and the third crusade is
the rise of Saladin
>> right
>> and especially right around 10 1170 is
where he really becomes prominent. He
takes over Egypt. Um and uh he becomes
assaulted of Egypt and uh he starts he
starts be after he uh wins over more
Muslim territories and brings them under
his control he essentially starts to
surround the crusader kingdoms which was
his plan um to completely surround them
>> cuz Alexa has got to be reclaimed.
>> Yeah. And
>> presumably that's the the prize. Am I
right thinking? Is that the prize goal?
>> Yeah. He well actually the fellow before
Okay. Remember Zenji, the guy I told you
who did Adessa, who conquered Adessa.
His son, Nural Dein, is really the is
the man or the sultan who's credited
with bringing back jihad. Okay? So, it
no longer became just, oh, we're
fighting these Franks. It became an
articulated jihad. And that man, Nural
Dean, had [snorts] all sorts of uh, you
know, booklets and books about the jihad
and the hadith about the jihad taught.
And so he really propagandized jihadist
rhetoric. Saladin who actually worked
under him originally, he was young, much
younger [clears throat] but then took
over also played the same game. He
presented himself and he also uh
marshaled jihadist war logic against the
infidel. So he definitely used that and
which is to go to your point. Also was
very important. We have to cleanse it
from these filthy infidels.
>> Right. Okay. So and this is also when
Richard the Lionheart is coming on the
scene. Is this how much were the English
involved in the Crusades before Richard
the Lionheart?
>> They were always involved right from the
beginning and not necessarily in huge
numbers. Mostly like I said if I were to
give it an in order I would say it was
the Franks and then the Normans and then
a sprinkling of everyone else.
>> Okay. Um
>> but Normans obviously conquer 1066. So
they are in control in uh in England. So
there is a
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> Well, yeah. The battle of Hastings in
1066 is just a few, you know, few
decades before the first crusade. Um,
but before the third crusade and before
we get to Richard, the most pivotal
event happens is that Saladin conquers
Jerusalem.
>> Right.
>> Okay. In uh 118,
the battle of hast, the battle of uh
Hatton in 1187,
>> which is the subject of the film with
Orlando Bloom.
>> Right. Right.
>> I forgotten the name of the film.
>> Yeah. Kingdom of Heaven. Kingdom of
Heaven, which I think the last time we
spoke you expressed quite [snorts]
deep umbrage with them.
>> It's an amusing movie, but it's
historically inaccurate
>> because [clears throat] you think they
glossed Saladin.
>> They Yeah. that and they make the they
make the Templars they basically in
these movies what they do is they take
the guys who are like religious and make
them into fools and then they take the
guy who not that you know Baian the way
they portray him he was not like that at
all like some kind of secular dude who's
like can we all live along that that was
anacronistic what you're doing um so
they just they they remold and
reashioned the crusades after our image
basically and that's that's my main
umbrage with them
>> right Um so uh Salazin recaptures
Jerusalem and Richard the Lionheart
>> that's what propels the third crusade in
Richard Linhardt
>> and what's the story of Richard the
Lionheart then when he arrives in the
Holy Land
>> how does that go for him? So Richard
Linhardt only a couple years earlier
became king. His father King Henry II
died and actually both King Henry his
father and he had taken the cross uh for
uh meaning they were getting ready to go
to the Holy Land to help reclaim
Jerusalem but his father died. now he's
king it and that delayed him a little
bit to consolidate his power but also he
you know he created what's called a
Saladin tax or tithe to raise money from
the peasants to help with the war effort
and he actually did bring a very
substantial war machine um king Phillip
as well came and um they were the two
kings but Philip they came and they
fought and it's a lot of it is the the
third crusade is probably the most
savage of all
>> really like where the most brutal you
know just fighting and desperate oh
existential struggle you know I mean
>> is it the same motivations as you've
described before it's
>> even more
>> more so because
>> it's calcified even now
>> because there's Christian soldiers who
have lost their lives and so there's
there's to honor the the forefathers
yeah and we've we've had Jerusalem for
almost a century you know so it's very
brutal the idea of losing it again was
just uh traumatizing and the Muslims are
now in the war path and they're the
jihadist logic. So, it was extremely
violent. Um, but the end of it is uh
they don't reclaim the holy land, but
they make a lot of progress. Right
before the third crusade, before Richard
came, Saladin's grand wish was to expel
all the crusader kingdoms. So, he took
Jerusalem and he would and he took
others, but there were still, of course,
little pockets here and there. Uh the
biggest one was Aker or Akre uh which he
actually did conquer for a little while
and then when Richard came and Philip
the war started there until they
reclaimed Aker the Christians and that
became the new the kingdom of Jerusalem
was there now.
>> Ah okay.
>> So that became the new Jerusalem uh kind
of like a temporary area.
>> Um
>> but Jerusalem was never captured again.
>> No it was never captured again. the but
you know after the after the third
crusade um they made peace and
Christians were allowed to go back to
Jerusalem as pilgrims and not be
molested you know so so there were so
what Richard did is um you know he made
sure that the that Saladin didn't
culminate what he wanted to by expelling
them entirely which he came close to
doing um so he gave them breather brea
breathing room uh basically Richard for
almost another another century and he
reclaimed he won back a few territories
stories that Saladin had conquered as
well but not Jerusalem. So that after
the first crusade really the third
crusade is considered the most
successful, right?
>> Okay. Though it didn't achieve its
ultimate goal,
>> right?
>> Um and then you know we we talked about
the fourth crusade.
>> Fourth crusade. Yeah. So uh at this
point and now we're talking sort of
1202.
>> Uh so we've we've had over a century.
>> Um
>> but it seems to go this is this is just
wore out the window. They try and sack
Constantinople from the Christians. Who
are the fourth crusade crusaders? Who is
it that's leading this? Why does it go
so arai arai in in
motivation and everything? What what
what happens here?
>> Okay, so it's a group of crusaders. They
were supposed to head to Egypt because
at this point now Egypt has become the
focal point of the crusade.
is way Richard wanted was wanted to
attack Egypt and the idea was you can
never hold Jerusalem without taking
Egypt because that's where all the
manpower was constantly coming from and
so they needed ships and they got these
Venetians to build them ships and then
when the time came uh only a few
crusaders showed up and others because
they went different routes and they
couldn't pay for the ships and the
Venetians you know got held them
accountable and said you know you owe
you you owe us money and this this was a
big thing of force at the time. So they
made a deal with them. The Venetians
said they have they had some enemy, some
business trade enemy, a Christian. Okay.
And they said, "If you join us to help
conquer them,
>> we'll call it even. Okay. You don't have
to pay for the ships."
>> Yeah.
>> And they did that and they conquered
>> and then um uh and then after that after
that when they did that, that was
already a small group of crusaders and
they got excommunicated for it. Okay? So
the pope immediately unulled them and
said, "You're out. You're you're not
even Christians at this point." Okay. So
they were so again so again you see that
the official leaders were against it the
pope.
>> Um and then that that same group somehow
ends up in this a Byzantine kind of uh
literally Byzantine as labyrinth and and
warped relation with a ousted Byzantine
prince who wants to come back and
reclaim his throne. And he wins them
over and says if you help me get
Constantinople I'm going to help you
with the crusade and I'll give you
money. And you know they help him. Long
story short, everything goes ary and
before you know you got these that small
group of crusaders running a muck in
Constantinople.
>> But they do successfully sack it.
>> Yeah, they do.
>> Right. Pretty horrific. Yeah.
>> And how many people are killed in that?
>> Oh, a great many. Yeah. I don't have the
Christian.
>> Christians. Yeah. And uh but again that
those same crusaders are all
excommunicated by the church and
condemned. Okay. So that's what I mean.
you know, when you this was one of those
things that yeah, definitely went arry
and did not have official backing. So, I
think it was Pope Innocent III. He was
just outraged and mortified by what had
happened. Okay. And he completely
condemned it. Um, so yeah, it it's
people love to throw the fourth crusade
kind of like, haha, it's the aha moment,
which I don't really understand what it
is. They hope it's prove. Um, I'm not
I'm
>> Well, well, hang on a second. I mean, it
is a bit of an aha moment. I mean, I
guess you're trying to make the point
that this fourth crusade represents the
all of the crusades being
>> No, no. My point is that is that I never
for once think that the Crusades and the
Crusaders were angels. Okay. Uh this is
war. These are humans. There's bad
stuff's going to happen. Okay. The the
the motivation, the impetus for it is
good. Um and I think a lot of them did
behave incorrectly. But of course, man
being man, whether he's called a
Christian or not, it's going to engage
in attacking the Jews, attacking fellow
Christians, misbehavior. So, I think the
people who use it as an aha moment, they
almost think that I think or if you
speak well about the Crusades that
somehow I think it's always everywhere
perfect and idealistic. No, I mean, at
the heart of it is fallen corrupt man.
So, I expect all sorts of bad things. In
fact, the the shocker is that we didn't
get more of that sort of thing actually,
you know. So that's why I'm saying it's
it's not that much of an aha moment for
me because yeah, bad people do bad
things whether they call themselves
Christians or not. But the pivotal point
or the most important point to me is
that the official leaders were against
it. And that's really you can't if you
how can you attack an inst you can't
attack an institution if some of its
members go rogue. Yeah. Even though the
leaders say and condemn them. So I don't
think it's as much of an aha moment that
people like to use as as they think it
is.
>> So we've still at this point got another
sort of hundred years of several other
crusades which we don't have time to go
into
>> less than 100 but yeah
>> less slightly less than 100 um and
before uh the European Christians are
completely ousted from uh or I guess
there would have been some remnants
remaining. Um,
when it comes to the Templars and
Hospitalers, can you tie the bow on on
these? Cuz presumably they weren't
involved in the fourth crusade, right?
No. Right. They would have stayed in the
Holy Land.
>> Exactly. Cuz their whole purpose is the
>> Okay. So, what happens to these two
organizations? So as time goes by and
it's actually makes sense for us to kind
of speed up that last century after the
fourth crusade the knights of the temple
and hospital become more and more
central to any crusading venture because
what happens now is and this is the
whole story it's one of numbers okay the
crusaders from the start are a small
number because they're surrounded in by
a sea of Islam okay and they need they
always need to be replenished from
Europe and with every passing year the
the replenishing becomes less and less
and less in part because of
secularization
uh you know the the first crusaders it's
understood they were way more pious than
even the third and definitely more than
the fifth and you know okay um so
there's this sort of thing where they
become smaller and smaller in numbers
and a lot of the secular European
crusaders even the ones who were the
native they call them the natives who
were born there Franks that had been
there generations would sell their uh
landings and leave go to Europe because
it it was that dangerous so they started
filling the vacuum the night the
military orders. And so with every
passing year, we're now in the 13th
century, the 1200s, you find them more
and more at the heart of the the crusade
until we reach the final uh the final
siege of Aker in 1291, which is when
they get expelled and basically they're
in charge of the whole thing. The man
who's in charge is the master of the
temple, who's actually in charge of the
defense of Aker, and he gets killed, of
course. Um and in 1291, that's it.
That's the, you know, official
historical date where it all ends
because now with the final fall of Aker
and there's just a few more kingdoms and
they all capitulate because it's
pointless and that's the end of the
crusaders. They're they leave uh and
never really come back. But but before
but if we stick and if we talk about
that the especially the hospitalers
their crusade continues for many more
centuries
>> against who?
>> Well, you want me to get into it?
>> Well, we can we can say that. I'm sure
it's in the book.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, no, I want to get
into it. But I mean, if before we wrap
the bow on the Crusades and 1291, this
is another story, the Knights of the
Hospital and what they do, and I'll get
into it, but if you want to say anything
else about
>> Well, about
>> Crusades.
>> Uh, I mean, the the big question is what
you said earlier that you asked. Are
they glorious?
>> Okay, good. So, let's get to that. And
actually, I was already touching on that
with the numbers. So, a lot of
historians and critics of the of the
Crusades, they love to laugh and go,
"Oh, they lost. Who cares? What's there
to what's the point?" And [snorts] the
point isn't so much if they win or lost
u win or lose. It's uh what they
represented and what motivated them,
which we discussed briefly, but it's the
number game, okay? And I think the best
way to give you an analogy, to me, the
Crusades are actually very impressive
because they lasted as long as they did.
It's not that they failed. That was
destined. that that had to happen as
I'll explain but that they actually
persevered for two centuries is an
amazing testimony to you know a stalwart
will and what I mean by that is they
were think about what they did here's
what let me compare it to what Muslims
did and not just Muslims but any world
conquerors okay what they do is uh they
okay here's the Muslims they start in
Arabia and they they start conquering
right so they conquer Syria and Egypt
and then once they consolidate them they
continue to Libya consolidate, continue
on to uh Algeria, Tunisia, consolidate,
get to Morocco, consolidate, get to
Spain. Okay? So, what they did, what
that does is you you you're always
conquering your immediate neighbor, and
that means I have all my manpower, all
my resources, all my fall back world
behind me, my reserves, right? And uh if
I lose, I'm just a a short march back
home where I'm safe. and if I win, well,
we consolidate this new territory, turn
it into ours, garrison it, and then
continue. That's the logical way to do
it. Okay? And that makes sense. Now, the
crusaders didn't do that because on the
one, the Muslims did that. Why? Because
who's their enemy? Well, it's their
neighbor. He's an infidel. Okay? You're
an infidel. That makes you our enemy.
We're going to conquer you. The
crusaders weren't about conquering
anyone because he's an infidel. They
were about the Holy Land, as we
discussed. So what that required is for
them to just hurl themselves into the a
sea of Islam instead of doing what
Muslims would have done which is conquer
it piece by piece that that wasn't their
purpose. They weren't out to conquer
Muslim lands. They just wanted the holy
land because of what was happening. M
>> so the fact that you had this tiny
dwindling you know Europeans in an ocean
of pure Islam and that's the whole point
they when you look especially at the
later battles and sieges it's kind of
like like one against a thousand okay
you have like uh 200 knights templers at
the battle of Aker the last one it's
just a few thousand fighters in total a
few hundred templars and hospitalers and
then you have something like 200,000
Muslims outside okay so that is the
tenor of the whole thing. And to me,
it's remarkable that that's the heroic
aspect that these guys could last for
that long for centuries. Um, and to give
you and by way of analogy, this would
require, for example, imagine if Muslims
instead of doing what I said they had
done. Um, you know, after they conquered
North Africa, they decided, you know
what, we're going to sell to France and
we're going to carve a little kingdom
right there. And, uh, and they do that.
And then all of all of Christendom, all
the Franks and the Germans and the
English and the Italians, all of them
can attack and do attack them and the
Muslims persevere and stay there for two
centuries. I think that would be seen as
very noble and heroic.
>> Although that happened in Spain for
eight centuries.
>> Yeah. But that was that's part of the
ongoing thing that I was describing. In
other words, they weren't an enclave.
Spain was connected to North Africa,
which was all Islamic,
>> right?
>> It's it's the Islamic advance. You see,
I'm talking about going in where the
whole thing is Muslim or Christian and
you're in the center by yourself. Okay?
So, the Spanish example would not be
that because that was after all of
Africa was taken, you know, straits of
Gibralar and then they went in.
>> So, my point is I do think
[clears throat] and it's this isn't even
what I'm saying to you isn't exactly
novel. A lot of people have said this uh
that's what makes them so heroic that
it's not that they lost, it's that they
could last for so long under such
amazing odds.
>> Right. So certainly remarkable. Glorious
though is still a word.
>> Yeah, glorious is a subjective thing and
it's
>> But you think they were glorious.
>> H Well, I mean
I don't use the word glorious often. So
probably I wouldn't use that word
glorious. I think they were remarkable.
I think they were heroic.
>> I tell you what is glorious. It's your
face under the beard. [laughter] But but
uh but you yeah they're remarkable.
>> Okay.
>> Um it's uh they're remarkable certainly.
I mean yeah I mean even I think uh their
Muslim opponents would have thought it
was like yeah and it comes out often in
the sources I quote them especially in
the two swords where the Muslims
especially uh they had this kind of
begrudging fear and and hate for the
knights of the temple in the hospital
because they saw them as the you know
the crack troops. These were like the
green berets of the crusades or the Navy
Seals.
>> I I'm sure historians don't like
moralizing or
uh engaging with uh trying to justify
things that happened in history. Uh cuz
I guess the the role of a historian is
to explain what happened and to try and
understand incentives. Uh but I think
there is a question about whether they
were in fact just wars. You might shut
this question down, but do you think any
of the crusades were just indeed?
>> Yeah. Okay. So they were just in the
sense that okay one the ter just war
what I'm going to say is what just war
does encompass okay so one it was
reclaiming lost territory that was
conquered okay as I told you when Islam
came on the scene all that territory
that they conquered including the holy
land was part of the Christian world
okay in the seventh cent in in the
seventh century this was it was part of
the Roman Empire okay and had been for
centuries so from their perspective this
was this is our territory You've stolen
it. You've conquered it. It's incumbent
on us to reconquer it. It's It's not
unlike the
>> I know that they thought it was just
war. I'm trying to ask whether you think
>> whether you think it was just war.
>> I I would agree with that logic. It was
Christian. It was conquered. And and
then, you know, adding insult to injury,
it wasn't just conquered, but the people
there were continuously oppressed. The
holy sites were continuously attacked.
So it wasn't just okay we conquered but
we're going to allow you to like for
example they say the Mongols were pretty
tolerant right Mongols would conquer
people and they were pretty brutal but
you can have whatever religion you want
uh under Islam yeah you can have your
religion but you're going to be
basically a degraded secondass citizen
and lose all sorts of rights um in fact
it's funny because a lot of times the
Mongols actually didn't like the Muslims
in the early stages and one of the
things they would always do is when they
would conquer an Islamic region is give
full rights to Christians and Jews and
that would upset the Muslims would write
about how
>> are we talking about Genghaskhan now?
>> Yeah. Well, not not him. He didn't reach
the Muslim lands. He had died. But his
his sons, his sons, his sons, grandsons.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. But they were eventually converted
to Islam.
>> Well, yeah. One group of them, the the
Golden Horde up by Russia. Um, which is
the the the Central Asian states now,
the descendants of it. Um, but so yeah,
it it's just in the sense that this was
seen as and I yeah, I see it like that.
I wasn't expecting that. Not just a
crusader apologist, but a Genghaskhan
apologist
>> all in one. Talk about controversial
opinions.
>> No, not apologizing for Genghaskhan.
[laughter]
But it was kind of cool. No.
>> Um, no, but the Mongols are known. I
mean, they were as brutal as anyone
gets. You know, the their infamous
mountains of But it's also interesting
to skulls and human heads. Um, but it's
also interesting to note that uh
history's most savage of all Mongol Turk
warlords was Muslim. And I'm talking
about Teamer Lang, Timur the Great,
Teamer the Lame.
>> Um, and it's interesting, too, because a
lot of historians like to distance him
and say, "No, no, he wasn't Muslim."
>> Yeah. Yeah. And he he claimed to be a
descendant of Genghaskhan, but some say
he really wasn't. Um but it's
interesting because even he actually
fought the um the hospitalers the
knights of the hospital in person.
Really?
>> Yeah. When he was a very very old man.
>> And what period are we now?
>> So this is right around very late 1200s
early 1300.
>> Timlain is in the European imagination
as well. I think it's Marlo who wrote a
play. It was wasn't it? So these these
characters really do make it all the way
across the other side of the European
continent.
>> Yeah they do. Um, especially Timberlank.
Uh, he he's I mean arguably the greatest
warlord.
I don't mean in a moral sense. I'm just
saying as far as a tactician and a
strategist and and his far
uh sprung conquests of people, I don't
think he ever lost the battle. So, look,
I don't want to discourage people from
you reading your book, and I'm sure like
last time, by the way, I told you this
off camera, but it it's sold out in the
UK off um on Amazon after uh our
conversation. Um but the the Templars
and the Hospitalers or the hospitals
uh continue after um this period. Now,
we don't need to have that whole that's
that's part three. Uh but maybe you give
me a taste.
>> Sure. Uh let's leave the Templars for a
bit because uh their their their history
is going to end quickly in Merkel in a
very graphic way. So let's look at the
hospitalers. Um they actually they're
still alive actually [laughter] as an
order. They still exist. But um so
basically after the fall of Aker, they
are now in Cyprus. Uh that's now the
closest Christian kingdom to the
Mediterranean. They have a base there
and they're still making plans on
getting back to to Jerusalem. But lads,
>> but yeah, and no, but no more Europeans
are just not buy. No one's doing it
anymore. So, they're just alone. Um, so
what they said, what they do is they
still want to protect pilgrims,
whichever are coming because remember
pilgrimage was not just something you do
when it's safe. You do it when it's not
safe and you think you might die and
that's part of the that's part of the
risk, you know. So,
>> but they became a naval power. So, first
they took over the island of roads.
Okay. Right. you know, southwest of the
modern day Turkey. And this was at the
time of the rise of the Ottomans, okay?
And in the south, you have the Mamluks
who actually were the ones who evicted
the crusaders out in 1291. And they they
start patrolling the seas and and
becoming basically helping Christian
merchants and pilgrims against Muslim
pirates who were attacking them
>> at the time. Okay. And they roads
becomes fortified. It became arguably
the most fortified kingdom in the world.
It was just if you it's you can still
see it too till this very day. And they
and they become a thorn in the Ottoman
Sultan side. Okay. Now this is the rise
of the great Ottomans who terrorize
everyone. But they can never get rid of
these guys. And uh finally in 13 you
know Muhammad the conqueror of
Constantinople Mhmed or Muhammad II who
conquered in 1453. He couldn't stand
these guys because they were always, you
know, like a nuisance. Yeah. Okay.
They're not a big threat, but they're
always messing with his plans. So,
finally in uh in 1479 or 1480, he said,
"That's enough." And he raised a
humongous army uh Armada and went and
they still lost the Muslims
>> and he he was very furious with it. And
he ended up dying
>> like a few months after that. Um so he
that was like a big win. A lot of you
know the the Christians in Romania I
think they all Christians were singing
the praises of the knights for being
able to withstand all the power that the
Ottomans who had just conquered not just
[clears throat] Constantinople but after
1453 many more regions of European
region and they couldn't take the the
little island of the knights. Wow.
>> So, it just shows you. And then,
>> long story short, finally they do get
evicted in 1522 by Sullean the
Magnificent. Um, and they they become
the homeless hospitalers. They're living
basically in boats until Charles the 5th
gives them Malta. Okay.
>> And this is an altruism. Yeah. This is
an altruism. He actually puts them there
because now this is the time of the
great uh these always existed. But now
the the early the early 16th century is
the beginning of the mass slave raids.
Muslim Barbary Coast attacking European
um
>> that starts as early as the 16th
century.
>> Yeah. In the early 1500s.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and one of the reasons that uh
Charles gave them Malta is he wanted
them right there in the center of the
Mediterranean to work as a guard patrol
which they did.
>> Wow.
>> And Yeah. And and very frequently they
um you know uh prevented the the Barbie.
Now, this is a time very interesting in
and of itself uh because this is when
mass slavery is going on um in North
Africa in the Barbar Coast.
>> Not only that, you also have the Turks
now well into Europe. Yeah. So, they're
we're filming in Budapest now. They're
actually they're not they're here.
They're
>> so the Ottoman Ottoman Turks are all
throughout the Balkans in Budapest
enslaving the Crime the Tartars who
became Muslim, the Golden Horde in the
Crimean uh peninsula, they're mass
slavers of the Slavic peoples. And then
you got the Muslims of North Africa, the
Barbrey, mass slavers of the
Mediterranean. Yeah. Okay. Millions and
millions of Christians and Europeans are
being enslaved.
>> Millions and millions.
>> Yeah. Millions and millions.
>> Because the I I looked at this a little
bit. I think it was about a million.
>> No. No. Okay. Well, you the I think what
you're citing.
>> Oh, sorry. I mean the Barbie pirates
alone. I'm not including
>> the Barbie pirates between 15 something
like 1580 and 17 80 or 1540 like for in
a 250 year period up to 1.25 million.
But that's just that I'm talking about
the Turks. I'm talking about the the
Crimeans
and um uh you know it's you want to hear
a little irony is some a modern day
development. Um so you're familiar with
Barbrey and what they did and how bad it
was and the worst slave market was in
Alers. Okay. And Alers actually provoked
and attacked the United States into its
first war. We cover this. We did. But
why it's interesting is uh on Christmas
Eve, this last one, the the Algerian
Parliament um in some kind of new law
scathing France, calling them evil
criminal criminal colonizers and
demanding reparations.
And I I I think they overlook the irony
that whatever France did during the
colonial era, which feel free to condemn
all you want, that's fine. Um, what
about what you guys did for three
centuries actually enslaving Europeans
and French and Americans? Where's the
reparations there? So, it just shows you
the, you know, the the extreme
hypocrisy.
>> They even conquered parts of England.
Lundy Island.
>> Lundy Island. Exactly. So,
>> for 5 years, the Corsair ran that
>> and went to Iceland and, you know,
Denmark, Ireland, Baltimore, and
Ireland. this what's as you know we
talked at the beginning of this
conversation a little bit about what was
Islam in the imagination of the
Europeans but even [snorts] if you go
all the way to now we're we're about a
almost a thousand years later aren't we
um and so we're more than a thousand
years later uh but if you also look at
literature so in the European
imagination certainly in the English
imagination we'd have thought about the
Muslim pirates in North Africa or in
coming from uh what we now call the
Middle East as a a serious threat. Um
and this comes up in literature. Last
time I I think I mentioned with uh uh
Daniel Defo and Robertson Crusoe, he's
captured by Corsair pirates.
>> I picked up on this recently, but in NA
CS Lewis describes I forgotten what the
the southern enemy is called, but they
have scimitars
>> and they're not explicitly Muslim, but
they it's all the imagery of this too
>> did it as well. simars and the same sort
of the southerners I think they call
>> Easterlings. Right. So this is in uh the
literature and the imagination. I I I
wonder if the English
rule Bratana song we shall never be
slaves has that in in their imagination.
Thomas Pello was one of the Englishmen
captured I think from Devon
>> and wrote diaries which you couldn't
even read his diaries.
>> No.
>> And he would have been a very famous in
England at at the time. Daniel Defoe
couldn't have done that book which was a
bestseller at the time if being caught
by slave made a slave wasn't in the
English imagination.
>> Cvantes.
>> Cvantes. Right. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly.
>> Doniote the author. Um, yeah, actually
you remind me of something funny that I
was observing the other day. And I don't
know if you if you have the same
observation, but if you if you look at
cartoons, you know, from, let's say, the
60s and 50s, uh, maybe even the '7s, but
50s, 60s, 40s, whatever, and you watch
pirates, I always would always, it would
interest me as a kid. I'd be like, why
do they always look sworthy and almost
like, uh, you know, maybe a relative of
mine? They, you know what I mean? They
were always dark and a beard and
scimitar. You have got a piratey vibe
actually. [laughter] That does make
sense.
>> Yeah. Well, I don't have the beard
anymore, but yeah, it'll be back. But um
but uh so even in the cartoons, I think
it was like like Popeye cartoons, it was
almost like carried like a cultural
memory that you know, a pirate was like
an Arab or a Muslim.
>> R Turbans. Yeah. And of course it's lost
now, you know.
>> But the interesting thing is is how it's
lost because even in Parliament, you can
hear what Churchill says about talks
about Muslims and Islam. William
Gladston, the liberal poem uh in the
19th century where he talks very
scathingly about Islam. It it's very
recent thing that the European
imagination
>> had felt differently and now it seems
like we're we're seeing a big shift
again against Islam. Uh now um
>> uh which so we're seeing this it's
almost like the blip in time was this
period
>> maybe from the 20th beginning of the
20th century to the end of the 20th
maybe that sort of period. Why do you
think that is? Why was there a change in
attitude towards Islam? Was do we have
bigger problems? Was it the second world
war was kind of was such a big first and
second world was so big that we
>> a lot it's a lot of it's all the above.
So one reason is you know if Islam went
from being this this massive problem for
for a millennium to just being nothing
okay it just like dissipate with the
right let's say around 1800 or 1798
which is sort of the symbolic date where
Napoleon goes and just immediately
conquers Egypt okay and then the
colonial era starts and now Islam is
just a spent force so for a lot of
Europeans um there's a great quote from
Hillera Bell I don't know if you're
familiar with him he was a prominent
intellectual ual uh I think he was born
8 late 1800s died maybe 1953 wrote a lot
about Islam and uh he has this really
important quote I have it I think in
swordar in my book in a conclusion where
he basically says I'm paraphrasing it
but pretty close he says you know the
white race the people of America and
Europe and Australia have forgotten all
about Islam and they just think if
anything um it's just a spent force or
it's a foreign religion has nothing to
do with me and then he says it is as a
matter of fact the most our most
persistent um and danger dangerous enemy
and could at any moment flare out again
as it did historically. He wrote this
around 1920 when Islam was like I said
nothing and the west was very powerful
and dominant and all over the Middle
East and Africa and Asia colonizing
>> and um so I mentioned that to you
because one you had intelligent and
precient people who got it. Two he was
pointing out that most people like you
said had Islam was no longer a factor.
It was more you know European powers
fighting each other. World War I, World
War II, that's the real threat. And then
when you move on now into the 50s and
60s and you have this, you know, the
whole new whatever word you want to give
it, you know, leftism, liberalism,
wokeism now. And uh all of a sudden now,
you know, the bad guys are always the
good guys and the bad the really bad
guys is the white guy and the Christian
and the good guys always the brown
victim. Okay? So for example, any you go
into history and you talk about Islam
and Europe, it's going to begin with the
colonial era. They're going to act like
everything before that there was, you
know, Muslims were peaceful or they or
they really want to stretch back.
They'll start it with the Crusades out
of context. None of the what I told you.
>> Raymond Ibraham goes a little bit
further back than all of that.
>> Yeah. I like to provide the full
picture. [laughter]
I like to give a little depth. So, um uh
yeah. So, I think uh even in the
academic world, we they just haven't
done justice to it and it's been colored
and marred by these uh liberal
philosophies where you know the noble
savage myth. Okay, we're basically white
evil European and everyone else is good.
That has become so ingrained. Okay, but
I think now now people because you can
only lie so much and pretend so much and
there's a reason for these fabrications.
Okay, and uh and I'll I'll give you a
perfect example. Let's look at um the
golden age myth without going without
going into details why why this argument
the golden age even matters and why
academics make it. This is the golden
age of Islam.
>> Of Islam, right?
>> Which is what period what are we what
are we talking about?
>> Well, usually there's two. The main one
is the Abbassads which I mentioned which
would be uh you know from let's say the
800 until 1200. Um I mean that's the
general year out of Baghdad. Is that
>> Yeah. But so from let's say 8 n uh 8 n
and or to give them the centuries 9th to
like 11th or 12th centuries
>> in Baghdad
>> and then there's the Cordoba. than the
Cordova in Spain which is a little
shorter and the idea behind those
>> which is a bit later is it
>> uh no no it's length in time it's yeah
it's under the Umayads um yeah it's it's
around the same time
>> but it doesn't last as long is what I
mean so uh the idea is that both of
these that this is the time where
Muslims are inventing and they're
advancing science and literature and
language while the savage Europeans are
wallowing in their huts or whatever
>> there's some evidence for that right
because Cordoba was the biggest city in
Europe I think that
>> no no there is evidence there I don't
deny that um that these areas were
definitely more if you wish civilized
and more advanced with better science
and technology and that sort of thing
but what now what we're not told okay is
that the people doing this because this
is still very early on and remember when
Muslims would conquer it's not like
everyone became a Muslim overnight uh
places like Egypt were still Christian
majority as late as maybe 13th and 14th
century okay Um, so why it's why I tell
you that is because Yeah. is because the
pe is the people who were doing the
golden age stuff were either Christians
or Jews or in Persia which is where the
Abbassads were, it was Persians,
Zorastrians or nominal.
>> Sorry. When you say they're doing that
those who are doing the achievements of
the golden age.
>> Okay. So what would be an example
famous? Give me some examples.
>> The names
>> the stuff that comes out is algebra.
Yeah. Yeah. Al Gabra. And
>> you're saying that that was not Muslims
who were
>> It was either
>> It was It was Muslims.
>> No. No. It was either non-Muslims or it
was nominal Muslims, which means it was
a guy who would just like yesterday was
a Jew or a Christian or a Zarastrian,
but converted because that's what you do
for social mobility. So, you know, if I
convert tomorrow to Islam, whatever
achievement I do, is it really something
we can attribute to Islam or to what
I've always been my whole life? You see
what I'm saying?
>> Mhm.
>> Um, so that's the argument. Now, I'm not
taking away from it. I'm just trying to
say that and and this is not from me.
There's a lot of excuse me um historians
who have who are dedicated to this topic
who've said the same thing. Okay, so
this is I'm not giving you some sort of
uh you know weird kind of Islamophobic
thing. A lot of historians who very well
credentialed make this point which is
yeah it happened but it happened despite
Islam not because of Islam. So you had a
Muslim ruling elite, Arabs, and they
allowed the people underneath them
because it was good for them to engage
in uh tech, you know, in whatever
discoveries and advancements which
benefited them anyway and they would
sponsor it. So that's all true,
>> but it wasn't because of anything
inherent to Islam. In fact, the more
Islam started to be codified and oified
because it wasn't codified at this
point. There's this famous time which is
I think in the 11th century where it's
called the doors of ished closed and
ished means or basically the doors for
free thinking in Islam closed and it
became literally oified okay and more
dogmatic. So the period we're talking
about is when is before that. So so
there were contending schools of law.
There were some that you would call
liberal okay which is good. Um but so
again it's but it's a hard stretch.
Here's the analogy I like to give which
may make sense.
Imagine if you go to um you know the
UAE, Dubai and these places that have
these massive skyscrapers, right? And
great technology and um impressive
architecture, more impressive than a lot
of things I see in the west. Okay? And
then imagine it's hundreds of years from
now and everything's been destroyed, but
those things are still standing there
and we the facts that we know is they're
there and we know that was a a Muslim
society. And then we conclude, aha, you
see what Islam did. Islam was
responsible for grand architecture that
the West could never rival. That's the
logic it would be. But you and I know
different. We know that yeah, it's a
Muslim nation. It bought it. It paid for
Westerners to build it and to sponsor
it. And yeah, it used its money which it
got from oil and uh so that's what it
really is. But you can see the
temptation without knowing that if we're
just people in posterity and we look
back and we can say, well, you see what
Islam created. Look at the wonders of
Islam. It's standing in a in an Islamic
region, this massive, you know,
skyscraper. So, I think that analogy
goes some way to um explain the golden
age. Um, but the reason I wanted to
bring it up to you is why the golden age
myth matters. Why why so much effort is
put by a lot of academics and people to
promulgate this? It's not because uh you
know well we want to make Muslims feel
good about themselves. I mean that may
be a superficial reason for some people
[snorts] but it actually has a very
practical effect and it is this if you
believe that that was the case if you
believe that somehow or other Muslims
during you know a certain period of time
historically were more advanced more
progressive more tolerant more civilized
than let's say Europeans and Westerners
then there is no way on earth we can
ever say that when Muslims act the way
they do now jihad terrorism that sort of
thing that that is innate to Islam
because it wasn't before. There was a
time when Muslims were actually the
progressive ones. So therefore, if
Muslims are running around saying jihad
and terrorism, that is not a reflection
of Islam, that's actually a reflection
of changing circumstances that are
bringing out this bad stuff. That is why
the golden age myth is so zealously
guarded. It's it's to throw a wrench in
the machinery. But if you know it's not
true, then it's easy for someone like me
to come and show you, well, look, they
were doing jihad back then and they're
doing jihad today, and there's a
straight line of continuity between the
two. That makes sense. But if you
believe that, no, there was a time when
they were tolerant, then you can't say
it's innate or intrinsic or inherent to
the religion itself, this jihad
business.
>> That's why these these um narratives are
created and so sacredly guarded.
>> Yes. Even though if you really look at
it, it doesn't
>> it's rhetorically useful and it's so
it's to create arguments particularly
when there are Islamist attacks as you
say
>> there's efforts to distance it from the
spirit of Islam and sayism
algebra algebra you know
>> right and part of that they need to
create a positive so there's a leaning
into that
>> and and in a more flagrant but less
successful uh and less uh less subtle
way is when they also try and they were
successful to suppress the Islamic
conquest of history which I've been
specializing in and talking about
because even that most people don't
know. You know if you know that okay if
you know there's a terrorist screaming
Allah Akbar and the Quran says kill you
but you're told that Islam spread
peacefully through trade well then that
guy doesn't really represent Islam. But
if you find no that's exactly what Islam
has done historically then that guy does
become an accurate representation of
Islam. And they don't want you to think
that. They always want you to think this
guy is a rogue wolf. He's a, you know,
he's not he's a he hijacked Islam for
his own evil purposes. But if you study
the real history, you see no, this guy
is in a long line of continuous um
iterations.
>> Well, on that topic, actually, there was
just a major Islamist attack foiled in
Britain over Christmas. It reportedly
would have been the biggest ever
Islamist attack in Britain in our
history. um or certainly in our modern
history and the uh attackers
uh called the they say wanted to attack
Jews first and foremost and then they
said something along the lines of once
we've got the Jews we'll go for the
crusaders. So as to our conversation
which tied it all together
>> certainly from these Islamist types they
they carry the me memory of the
crusaders um perhaps closer than
Christians do still today. And I I was
in Lebanon last summer and um I walked
into a mosque in Balbeck.
>> Mhm. [laughter]
>> Uh it was a it was a Hezbollah mosque
and it was sort of picture of Naza, but
there was a huge painting of a Christian
crusader surrounded by Muslim armies all
sitting there scimitars and
>> up. So the the the crusaders if it's not
in the western imagination although it's
also now increasingly in the western
imagination, not just a football games
are they wearing a crusader kit or the
hospitalist kit. Was it the hospitals or
the Templars? I don't know. I think
hospitals uh they uh there's more and
more reference to that. They're wearing
that sort of uniform at the protest we
see around uh Britain now. So So it's
it's returning in the
>> Yeah. It's it's never left the Muslims
you know they the Muslims to their
credit they don't change. Um they say
have the same worldview the same game
plan. Um they know their history even
though they take liberties and you know
make themselves look like the good guys
whenever they can. And that's kind of
normal, I guess, for different peoples,
except for Europeans who do the
opposite. And they go out of their way
to make their their history look even
worse than it was. But I think, yeah,
um, for the longest time, it's the West
that had forgotten its heritage. Um,
especially visav Islam. But yeah, like
you're saying, it's it's coming back.
That memory is coming back. Uh, and, uh,
>> it should be I mean, it could be a good
thing or a bad thing. I think it could
be a good thing if if it's um, channeled
correctly.
Well, on that note, Raymond, it's been
an absolute pleasure. Congratulations on
The Two Swords of Christ. I haven't read
it yet, but I look forward to it. Five
centuries of war between Islam and the
Warrior Monks of Christendom, part three
in your series. I hope there's a part
four and five and six.
>> Oh, there's many, many more coming.
>> And I hope there's also a part three
with you coming on the show. If you've
got the energy, I don't even know how
we're doing for time. I'm going to
invite you over to our subst to take
some quick questions from our loyal
substackers who have I've got more
questions for you than I think any other
guest. Okay.
>> Uh you're a popular one. Is there
anything else you'd like to bring
>> viewers attention to before we head over
there?
>> Well, no, I think this has been rather
comprehensive.
>> Wonderful. So, Raymond, thank you so
much.
>> My pleasure.
>> Bring the flame.
Bring back the fire and [music] the
rightous name.